Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 2. Nein, gar nicht wahr. 54 bin ich schon. Ich komme in letzter Zeit mit den Nummern durcheinander, weil so viel produziert wird. Ein Express folgt auf den anderen, aber so soll es ja auch sein. Also Nummer 54, ich bin mir sicher. Mein Name wie immer Tim Pritlove am Apparat und wir schreiben den 14. November 2007. Hurra, ich habe es nicht vergessen, das Datum zu erwähnen. Ich weiß nicht, ob das für dich wichtig ist, aber jetzt habe ich es zumindest mal getan. Ja, und neue Sendung, neues Thema. Ich begrüße erstmal den Gast und sage Hallo Sven. Jetzt musst du antworten. Ah, und ich muss dein Mikrofon einschalten. Zweiter Versuch.
Hallo Tim.
Okay, Sven, Sven Neumann. Du bist Software-Entwickler, kann man sagen, im Open Source Bereich. Und zwar schreibst du an einem Programm mit, was sicherlich vielen bekannt ist. Nämlich, wie sagt man, sagt man der Gimp oder sagt man Gimp?
Also mir ist es am liebsten, man sagt Gimp. Wir haben ein bisschen versucht, diesen Artikel loszuwerden in der letzten Zeit. Also es ist eigentlich Gimp und es ist das GNU Image Manipulation Program.
Genau. Gimp, the GNU Image Manipulation Program. Und da hört man natürlich schon raus, Gimp ist selbstverständlich freies Software, also wird unter der GPL veröffentlicht. Stimmt's?
Ja, das stimmt immer noch. GPL 2, aber das wird es wahrscheinlich demnächst auch ändern.
Ah.
In? Na, es gibt ein Update auf die GPL 3. Also erst mal, es gibt überhaupt eine neue Version der GPL.
Ja.
Die Version 3.
Und die ist fertig, ne?
Die ist fertig.
Das hat ja lange gedauert.
Einige Projekte haben wir auch schon angefangen zu wechseln auf die GPL 3. Und bei uns steht die Diskussion noch an. Aber es gibt durchaus einige Entwickler, die dasselbe fürworten. Und ich nehme an, dass wir es doch tun werden.
Was sind dir da so für Vorteile? Weil die ist ja nun, also GPL 3, die dritte Version der GNU Public License, der ja auch Linux unterliegt und viele andere Software-Pakete, die war ja extrem umstritten. War das dann bei euch auch so?
Wie gesagt, wir haben die Diskussion noch nicht wirklich geführt, weil wir gerade so ein bisschen damit beschäftigt waren, unseren Release zu machen, als dann die GPL 3 rauskam. Und irgendwo war uns das Richtige, einfach erstmal alle Kräfte zu fokussieren. 2.4 endlich den einen Streit erstmal beenden. Und zur Zeit bewegt sich so die Diskussion mehr ein bisschen mehr darum, was machen wir eigentlich mit 2.6. Und da wird sicher auch der Wechsel der Lizenz nochmal auf den Tisch kommen.
Okay, also greifen wir mal ein bisschen vorweg. Die aktuelle Version ist 2.4 frisch released.
Frisch released vor drei Wochen.
Also Anfang November, Ende Oktober.
Ende Oktober, 24. Oktober haben wir es eigentlich geschafft. 24.10, 2.4. Das war natürlich alles Absicht.
Okay, aber nur in der europäischen Schreibweise. Und das hat eine Weile gedauert, nicht? Also die Version davor.
Ja, das war auch schon ein Kraftakt. Gimp 2.2 release, was damals auch schon sehr lange gebraucht hat, war auch schon wieder fast drei Jahre her. Das war Ende 2004 quasi.
Das ist ein langer Marsch. Und wie fühlt man sich dann so, wenn das vorbei ist?
Ich bin sehr froh, dass wir es endlich geschafft haben, so viel fertig zu bringen, weil das halt doch die Zeit vor so einem Release immer etwas zäh ist. Man darf nicht mehr so richtig überall dran schrauben und man darf keine neuen Features mehr einbauen. Gerade wenn man als Maintainer die Hand drauf hat, dann muss man sich natürlich auch selber ein bisschen im Zaum halten. Und diese Zeit vor dem Release hat sich doch sehr lange hingezogen. Ich habe, glaube ich, schon vor fast zwei Jahren mal gesagt, wir sind eigentlich schon fast so weit. Es fehlt nicht mehr viel. Wir müssen bloß noch hier dies und das. Und hier braucht es noch ein bisschen was geschraubt werden. Und da ist was noch nicht fertig. Und wie das dann so ist? Das hat schon doch ziemlich lange gedauert. Was sicher auch daran liegt, dass unsere Ansprüche da recht hoch sind an so einem Release.
Wer entscheidet denn darüber, ob das nun fertig ist oder nicht?
Im Prinzip der Bug-Tracker. Nee, natürlich nicht. Aber irgendwann entscheidet man halt so, die Sachen müssen unbedingt noch fertig werden. Die Sachen müssen noch für das Release fertig werden. Weil sie angefangen sind und sie in dem Zustand, wie sie jetzt gerade sind, kann man sie einfach nicht lassen. Da funktioniert irgendwas nicht. Es ist vielleicht eine Regression. Also irgendwas, das in 2.2 funktioniert hat, was der User in 2.2 machen konnte, kann er in der Version nicht tun.
Weil ein neues Feature das komplett weggebügelt hat.
Ja, wir haben zum Beispiel ein paar Tools komplett umgebaut. Die sind quasi neu geschrieben worden. Die verhalten sich auch teilweise sehr anders, aber man will natürlich trotzdem die gleichen Arbeitsschritte damit durchführen können. Vielleicht etwas anders, aber du willst halt nicht sagen, wir nehmen dem User jetzt diese eine Möglichkeit, das Tool zu bedienen, komplett weg. Weil der Erfolg ist dann nachher, dass die Leute sagen, dann mache ich eben das Update nicht mit, dann bleibe ich bei 2.2. Und eigentlich ist es uns schon recht wichtig, dass so ein Release sehr stabil ist und dass es die Features hat, die das Release vorher auch hatte. Und dass es insgesamt eine runde Sache ist und nicht an allen Ecken irgendwo halb fertig.
Okay, das heißt, man kriegt schon mit so ein Release. Das ist eine ernste Sache. Das kann man nicht einfach auf die leichte Schulter nehmen. Ich will das auch gerne noch weiter vertiefen, was da sozusagen jetzt für Faktoren sind. Aber vielleicht sollten wir erstmal noch ein bisschen zurückspulen und einen wenig geschichtlichen Kontext bereitstellen für die Leute, für die Gimp jetzt nur so ein Wort ist. Es ist definitiv eine der bekannteren Stückprogramme in der Open Source-Welt, gar keine Frage, weil es auch schon sehr lange existiert. Letzter Zeit nimmt die Zahl von Open Source-Programmen für alle möglichen Anwendungen extrem zu. Ob die Qualität da auch in gleichem Maße zunimmt, sei noch mal dahingestellt. Aber man merkt, es geschieht jetzt was im Anwendungsbereich. Aber Gimp ist so, zumindest so für meine Erfahrung, die erste wirkliche vollständige Anwendung, die sich einfach um etwas kümmert, was nichts mit den grundsätzlichen Dingen wie Systemadministration, Development oder so zu tun hat, sondern wo wirklich das Bedürfnis von normalen Anwendern, in diesem Fall Leuten, die Bilder bearbeiten wollen, abgedeckt wird. Und das macht es natürlich schon zu einem besonderen Tool. Also ist ja auch schon länger da als Webbrowser. Jetzt komme ich ein bisschen ins Schlingern. Deswegen wollte ich da mal einsteigen. Wann ging denn das los mit Gimp?
Es gab eine erste öffentliche Released-Version, die Version 0.5.4. 1995 bereits, also vor über zwölf Jahren, ist das ganze Projekt das erste Mal an die Öffentlichkeit gegangen. Das war einfach ein Programm, das zwei Leute an der Uni geschrieben haben.
1995, also vor locker zwölf Jahren. Das ist ja schon erstaunlich. Und das lief dann unter Linux? Nur.
Das lief damals auf allen Systemen, wo du einen Motiv zur Verfügung hattest.
Also Motiv ist diese, wer hat denn das überhaupt erfunden? Ist das von der USF oder haben die das nur später übernommen? Das war so dieses frühzeitliche GUI für Unix-Systeme, was noch sehr einfach daher kam, so mit diesem etwas schäbigen 3D-Look.
Das ist halt ein sogenanntes Toolkit. Also das, was halt so Knöpfe, Schaltflächen zeichnet, irgendwelche Schieberegler, wo vielleicht auch mal ein Dateiauswahl-Dialog und ebenso die Bausteine, aus denen man in User Interface zusammensteckt. Und das war damals noch Motiv, was ein kommerzielles Toolkit war, was allerdings für private Zwecke, und ich glaube vor allen Dingen für Forschungszwecke, bekam man eine Version, die man verwenden konnte. Man konnte damit zwar noch nicht selber Software kompilieren dagegen, aber man konnte immerhin Motiv-Programme im universitären Umfeld benutzen, ohne dafür Lizenzgebühren zu entrichten.
Und darauf lief Gimp. Und wer hat das entwickelt? Von wem stammt das? Das ist ja nicht von dir.
Das ist ja nicht von euch. Nein, nein, das waren zwei Studenten in Berkeley, Kalifornien.
Wie heißen die?
Das war Peter Mattis und Spencer Kimbell, von denen man in letzter Zeit auch nicht mehr so viel gehört habe. Das letzte, was ich gehört habe, war, dass sie bei Google arbeiten. Zwischendurch hatten sie sich auch mal mit einem Online-Fotodienst versucht. So ein bisschen bevor es Flickr gab, gab es mal was von den beiden. Aber so richtig haben sie es damals nicht geschafft.
Und die haben einfach mal losgekurdigt. Die waren der Meinung, wir brauchen jetzt Bildbearbeitung.
Die hatten irgendwie einfach wahrscheinlich das Bedürfnis, Bilder zu bearbeiten. Und haben sich gedacht, wir brauchen das. Es gibt hier auf diesem ganzen Free-Software-Bereich eigentlich nur Texteditoren, Compiler und was so eben der Entwickler braucht. Aber das, was man einfach braucht, um mal irgendwie vielleicht den Grafik für seine Webseite zu machen oder die Fotos aus einer Digitalkamera oder aus dem Scanner zu bearbeiten, das war ja 1995.
Also die Webseite war schon relativ fortschrittlich.
Ja, also die erste Ankündigung von dem Raum tatsächlich in den News. Also etwas, was heute ja auch irgendwie unüblich ist. Ich glaube, ich habe kein Release-Announcement in Newsnet gemacht für das 2.4-Release, aber die ersten belegten Erwähnungen von Gimp stammen sozusagen aus dem Newsnet.
Ja, das war ja damals noch so der öffentliche Teil des Internets eigentlich. Da hat man sich unterhalten, wo auch sonst. Also klar, Mailing-Listen, aber Slashdot gab es noch nicht. Und auch nichts Ähnliches. Jetzt gibt es ja auch etwas, das heißt GTK, das Gimp-Toolkit. Was hat das mit dem Gimp zu tun?
Da können wir quasi gleich an das Motiv von vorhin anknüpfen. Das war schon eine etwas schwierige Sache, dass da ein nicht freies Toolkit verwendet werden musste, um eben diese freie Software zu kompilieren. Und das war auch etwas, was den Entwicklern tatsächlich auch diesen beiden Peter und Spencer damals schon gestunken hat, dass sie auch Bugs in Motiv eben nicht beheben konnten, weil sie einfach den Source-Code davon nicht hatten. Und deren gab es wahrscheinlich viele. Deren gab es viele. Dann muss man mit Workarounds arbeiten. Das ist das Schlimmste, was einem Programmierer passieren kann, dass er genau weiß, da hinten ist irgendwas nicht in Ordnung und ich muss jetzt hier einen Aufwand treiben. Und könnte er eigentlich, wenn ich da unten nur reinkäme, könnte ich da die eine Stelle ändern. Und so haben sie ihr eigenes Toolkit geschrieben. Damals noch als Teil von GIMP selber wurde GTK entwickelt, das GIMP Toolkit. Und das ist das Toolkit, wo heute der GNOME Desktop drauf basiert. Das ist halt irgendwann dann im Laufe der Entwicklung zu GIMP 1.0 wurde GTK dann abgespalten und wurde zu einem eigenen Projekt und wird auch inzwischen von mehr oder weniger komplett anderen Leuten entwickelt und maintained. Das ist aber immer noch die Grundlage.
Okay, das ist so ein typischer Fall von wir brauchen mal was und dann hackt man sich das und dann fällt was ganz Neues dabei ab. Im Prinzip war das ja dann so die Geburtsstunde eines Open Source GUI-Basis-Systems. Ich weiß nicht, warum sich das GTK in der ersten Version so gekümmert hat, aber es war am wesentlichen wahrscheinlich das, was du vorhin schon gesagt hast. Button, Fensterrahmen.
So ein Grafikprogramm braucht eigentlich so ziemlich alles, was man in so einem Toolkit so benötigt.
Was benötigt man in so einem Toolkit?
Du willst irgendwie Fenster aufmachen können, an den Screen bringen, du willst Menüs haben, Pop-up-Menüs, Menü-Leisten, Toolbars, einfache Buttons, Slider, dann irgendwelche relativ speziellen Widgets sind auch immer noch in GTK, weil es halt ursprünglich mal von Gimp kommt, wie zum Beispiel diese kleinen Lineale, die so links und oben an der Bildfläche in Grafikprogrammen zu finden sind, wo man dann die Pixelposition ablesen kann. Also sowas ist eben Teil eines Toolkits.
Und das ist dann alles in GTK gelandet und der Gimp hat sich dann sozusagen, jetzt habe ich schon wieder der Gimp gesagt, tut mir leid, Gimp hat sich dann sozusagen auf das Wesentliche konzentriert. Und was ist jetzt das Wesentliche? Also was macht, das haben wir ja noch gar nicht gesagt, also was macht den Gimp? Also Image Manipulation, da gibt es ja verschiedenste Ansätze. Wofür ist es gemacht?
Ja, es gibt auch verschiedene Dinge, die man mit Gimp machen kann. Die einen mehr oder also die einen besser, die anderen vielleicht nicht so gut, aber im Endeffekt, es dreht sich immer um Bilder und zwar Pixelbilder, die pixelbasiert sind. Also da, wo es wirklich darum geht, ich habe hier 1024x768 Pixel und die möchte ich in irgendeiner Weise bearbeiten. Vielleicht ist es ein Foto und ich möchte irgendwie einfach nur einen Farbstich entfernen und das Ganze ein bisschen heller machen oder vielleicht ist da aber auch jemand drauf, der ich da nicht drauf haben will und den möchte ich da entfernen. Man kann auch mehr oder weniger gut damit auch Bilder erzeugen. Also man fängt einfach an mit einem weißen Blatt und fängt dann an zu malen, wobei der Fokus liegt nicht so sehr da drauf, wirklich ein Programm zu sein, mit dem Künstler quasi die Arbeit auf Aquarelle oder Wasserfarben oder irgendwas simulieren können.
Aber 1995, da gab es ja noch gar nicht so viele Fotos. Also da gab es ja noch nicht so viele.
Web ist sicher auch schon immer eine Anwendung gewesen.
Ja, ich vermute, ging es vielleicht am Ende tatsächlich um das User Interface selber. Also war dann sozusagen der Gimp auch das Tool, um sein eigenes User Interface zu malen? Oder ist das jetzt ein bisschen zu sehr hineininterpretiert?
Na ja, man will ja, wenn man User Interface macht, auch gerne mal sich vorher ein Bild machen, wie sowas aussieht. Und für sowas wird natürlich auch Gimp sehr gerne eingesetzt. Wobei da inzwischen so der Trend ist, dass man sowas auch gerne mit einem Vektorzeichenprogramm macht. Aber ursprünglich ist es schon so gewesen, wenn man ein User Interface Mockup, also so einen Entwurf, wie sowas aussehen könnte, macht, dass man dann sowas mit Gimp machen kann, da kann man Texte einfügen, da kann man vielleicht aus irgendwelchen Screenshots Dinge ausschneiden und die neu kombinieren, neu zusammenstellen.
Und dann ist das so ein...
Wobei das sicher mit der ersten Version fand Gimp noch schwierig gewesen. Also sowas wie Ebenen gab es damals noch nicht. Sondern du hast halt...
Dass man Bilder in unterschiedliche Ebenen aufteilt, die sich dann quasi auf dem Bildschirm dann vereinigen.
Ebenen kann man sich immer so ein bisschen vorstellen wie so ein Stapel von Folien. Wo man halt dann so Klarsichtfolien hat, wo einzelne Sachen drauf sind und die kann man unabhängig voneinander bewegen und kann auch mal eine rausnehmen. Und sowas gab es in der ersten Version halt noch gar nicht.
Das war einfach nur XY und G.
Da konntest du, wenn du so einen Effekt machen wolltest, wie eine Schrift, die so ein Bild abdeckt, dann konntest du irgendwie das Bild haben und dann musstest du ein zweites Bild machen, was genauso groß ist, dann den Text eingeben, in schwarz-weiß oder so. Und dann konntest du mit einer Additionsoperation diese beiden Bilder zusammenfügen. Das ist ein drittes Erzeugt. Es war schon ein bisschen umständlich.
Es gab ja auch nicht so viel damals.
Es hat schon Spaß gemacht. Es gab tatsächlich schon ein bisschen Internet. Es gab halt Tutorials, wo die Leute gezeigt haben, wie man mit diesen einfachen Mitteln sich schon ganz entsprechende Effekte machen kann, für die man sonst halt sich teure, kommerzielle Software anschaffen muss.
Denn Gimp war natürlich kostenlos, wie es ja auch heute noch ist. Weil es ja Open Source ist. Und wie ging das denn weiter? 1995, also Version 0.5.4, klingt jetzt noch nicht so entwickelt. Du hast gesagt, mit der 1.0-Version wurde das GTK abgespalten. Wann war es so weit?
Ich glaube 1997.
Also ein paar Jahre später.
Ich glaube, es ist 1.0-Release.
Wann hast du das das erste Mal in die Finger bekommen?
Das war tatsächlich in... Also angefangen zu entwickeln habe ich 1997 irgendwann und in die Finger gekriegt habe ich es schon so in der Version 0.6.0. Das ist so die erste Version, die ohne Motiv funktionierend war. Weil ich hatte damals auf meinem Rechner auch keins und hätte es auch entsprechend gar nicht benutzen können.
Und warum hast du dich dafür interessiert? Also bist du im Bildbearbeitungsbereich tätig gewesen?
Nein.
Du wolltest nur schicke Hintergründe haben.
Genau. Das hat sich quasi da so ein bisschen entwickelt. Die Tutorials, die es gab, haben mich irgendwie fasziniert. Und was mich schon damals sehr fasziniert hat, war, dass es schon in der frühen Version ein Scripting-Sprache gab. Und was man eben machen konnte, war das, was man da in den Tutorials liest, einfach mal in so einem Script nachzubauen. Und dann hatte man das plötzlich auf Knopfdruck und eben nicht mehr mühsam mit zig Bildern. Und wir kombinieren das mit dem und erzeugen ein drittes und so. Nein, man konnte es eben in den Script packen und damit so einfache Sachen machen, wie ein Drop Shadow, Kopie von einem Bild, in schwarz gemacht, ein bisschen geblurrt, nach rechts unten rausgeschoben.
Und schon hatte man so einen Schlagschatten. Genau. Das dauerte eine Weile, bis das so ein Standard-Feature war, ein Grafikprogramm. Und jetzt bist du ja, das haben wir vorhin schon verfallen, dass du mittlerweile einer von zwei Maintainern dieses Projektes bist. Was heißt das genau? Was ist ein Maintainer? Was macht der, was die anderen Programmierer nicht tun?
Naja, der hat so die ganzen unbankbaren Aufgaben. Der Maintainer kümmert sich unter anderem darum, dass die Releases gemacht werden. Das heißt, der sagt irgendwann so, heute ist der Tag gekommen. Und wir machen ja auch nicht nur diese großen Stable-Releases, sondern es gibt immer wieder Pack-Fix-Releases in der Stable-Tree. Und wir haben halt auch über die ganzen Jahre jetzt ja, wir waren nicht völlig in der Versenkung drei Jahre lang und haben an Gimp gearbeitet. Es gab regelmäßig Development-Releases, wo wir halt sagen, das hier ist nicht fertig, das ist eventuell auch instabil. Es kann sein, dass das einfach sofort auf die Nase fällt, aber dann würden wir auch gern davon hören, damit wir das im nächsten Vision fixen können. Und sowas macht halt ein Maintainer. Du guckst irgendwie, welche Features nehmen wir rein. Du guckst nach den Bugs, die im Bug-Trecker auflaufen. Du kümmerst dich darum, dass wenn Leute sagen, sie möchten gerne mitarbeiten, dass man sagt, ja, gerne. Wo sind deine Fragen? Was würdest du gerne machen? Du hast einen Code geschrieben, zeig mal her. Sowas muss ja auch gepflegt werden. Irgendjemand muss sich darum kümmern, dass das Ganze ein bisschen vorangeht.
Das heißt, du bist im Prinzip nicht nur du, sondern du.
Mit Mitch zusammen?
Mit Mitch zusammen, ihr seid zwei in dem Team. Ihr codet ja auch schon seit Ewigkeiten zusammen. Ihr seid dann sozusagen die Hausmeister und die Treiber, aber ihr codet auch viel. Ihr schafft auch ganz konkret Code im Gimp. Wahrscheinlich sogar mehr als andere? Ja, ich würde das so sagen.
Durchaus wesentlich mehr als andere. Mitch und ich hatten auch schon Zeiten, in denen wir noch wesentlich mehr Code geschrieben haben als heute. Da war es definitiv so, dass wir beiden das sehr vorangetrieben haben. Wir hatten ein paar größere Umarbeitungsprojekte in Gimp, wo wir den Code wieder auf Vordermann gebracht haben. Das Chaos von Jahren, was zusammengewachsen war, hat irgendwie funktioniert, hat wieder in einen Status gebracht, wo man damit auch wieder arbeiten kann und wo man auch wieder neue Features einbauen kann. Das ist schon etwas, was in weiten Teilen von uns beiden gemacht wurde.
Wie seid ihr denn überhaupt dazu gekommen? Ihr seid ja nicht morgens aufgewacht und wart ihr maintainer, sondern am Anfang warst du ja erst mal nur irgendjemand, der diese Software ausprobiert hat. Dann hast du angefangen daran mitzuprogrammieren?
Ja, dann habe ich zwei, drei solche Skripte geschrieben und habe die mal auf die Mail-In-Liste gepackt. Dann habe ich angefangen, in dem Skript und in dem Skript noch einen Bug zu fixen. Und dann irgendwann auch mal den ersten in dem Programm selber, den ich so bei der Arbeit an den Skripten gefunden habe. Und irgendwann haben die gesagt, sag mal, willst du dich nicht um die Skripte kümmern? Und dann habe ich halt erst mal eine Zeit lang so ein bisschen so die Skripte gemacht. Und dann wurde das aber eigentlich...
Was heißt denn die Skripte? Also die Skripte, mit der man Dinge innerhalb von Gimp automatisieren kann, die mit dem Programm ausgeliefert werden, um diesen Bestand hast du dich gekümmert?
Ein bisschen darum mich gekümmert, dass da ein paar neue Sachen aufgenommen werden, dass das alles ein bisschen schicker wird, dass das User Interface von den Skripten mal ein bisschen ansehnlicher wird.
Ist das auch so eine Skriptsprache mit so einem komischen Namen, oder mit so einem komischen... was ist denn das?
Ja, das ist Skript Foo, und das basiert auf Scheme. Scheme in One Day war das zumindest damals noch, der Scheme-Interpreter, und das ist so eine...
So eine funktionale Programmiersprache ist das.
So eine funktionale Programmiersprache, die Leute, die Lisp kennen. Das ist auch so dieselbe Ecke. Das ist das mit den ganzen vielen Klammern.
Aber bei Skript Foo gibt es nicht so viele Klammern.
Bei Skript Foo gibt es auch diese Klammern.
Aber man kann trotzdem was damit anfangen? Oder hält es die Leute da genauso vom Programmieren ab?
Ich halte es eigentlich auch nicht für so die gute Skript-Sprache, die man eigentlich sich so in seinem Programm einbauen will. Was sehr gut ist, ist, dass Gimp schon von vornherein Skripting mit drin hatte und deshalb irgendwie Skripting im Ansatz schon immer unterstützt war. Inzwischen haben wir halt auch andere Programmiersprachen, die sich meiner Meinung nach doch wesentlich besser eignen, um mal eben schnell kurz mal was zu skripten. Weil das ja eigentlich das, was es sein soll. Also Pearl gibt es jetzt schon seit längerem als Skript-Extension. Und was wir jetzt gerade auch in 2.4 nochmal sehr forciert haben, ist die Entwicklung von Python.
Was ja auch dafür gerade zu gedacht war.
Und das ist halt wirklich wesentlich angenehmer hinzuschreiben, zu lesen als auch zu maintainen.
Da gibt es ja vor allem auch einen riesigen Stamm an Python-Programmierern, auf die man jetzt zurückgreifen kann. Genauso bei Pearl natürlich. Aber so Skript-Fu gibt es ja in dieser konkreten Ausprägung eben nur in Gimp.
Es hat eine unheimlich weite Verbreitung dadurch, also Skript-Fu, dadurch, dass es auf allen Plattformen installiert ist. Weil der Interpreter Teil von dem Gimp-Paket ist, kannst du davon ausgehen, wenn du deine Dinge in Skript-Fu programmierst, dass es auf allen Gimp-Installationen funktioniert. Das ist etwas, was wir jetzt mit Python...
Aber bei Version 2.4 ist ja auch Python dabei.
Python ist zum Beispiel unter Windows auch nur dann dabei, wenn auch Python schon installiert ist bei dem User. Man hätte sich jetzt vielleicht auch noch dazu entscheiden können, auch noch Python mit in den Installer rein zu tun, aber dann wird es dann doch langsam ein bisschen viel. Und soweit ich weiß, hat der Windows Installer jetzt das Python-Plugin zwar dabei, also die Python-Extension und auch die Standard-Skripte, die werden aber nur dann funktionieren, wenn der User sich auch vorher Python für Windows installiert hat. Und die Windows-User sind halt schon ein großer Bestandteil unserer User-Basis.
Der größte?
Ich würde sogar sagen, der größte. Es ist ein bisschen schwierig, das zu sagen, weil man hat halt nicht so richtig Zahlen.
Genau. Aber jetzt sind wir gerade abgekommen, weil eigentlich hast du ja erzählt, wie du Maintainer geworden bist, du und Mitch. Also du hast jetzt angefangen, Code beizutragen und dann?
Schleichend sozusagen. Man macht halt ein bisschen Code und noch ein bisschen mehr Code. Und dann habe ich... Es hat eine Weile gedauert. In der Zwischenzeit haben sich zwei, drei Maintainer abgelöst. Und irgendwann war es dann halt mal so weit, dass Josh gesagt hat, sag mal, ich werde in der nächsten Zeit nicht so viel Zeit haben. Und sehe nicht so ganz, wie ich das schaffen soll. Wollt ihr beide nicht oder einer von euch beiden?
Das heißt, zu dem Zeitpunkt waren jetzt die ursprünglichen Programmierer gar nicht mehr dabei? Oder haben zumindest nicht mehr diese führende Rolle gespielt?
Nee, die haben 1996 irgendwann an der Uni ihre Abschlussarbeit machen müssen.
Ach so, das heißt, die haben also eigentlich nur losgetreten?
Die haben das losgetreten, haben wohl schon auch einiges von dem ursprünglichen Design gemacht und auch das Gimp Toolkit mit auf die Beine gebracht, waren dann aber irgendwann weg.
Das heißt, die haben eigentlich nur so die Weichen gestellt und dann sind die anderen losgefahren und haben was draus gemacht. Aber es ist ja eigentlich ganz cool, wenn so ein Projekt auch so lange weiterlebt und dann von Hand zu Hand weitergereicht wird. Und dann ist es irgendwann bei euch gelandet. Und war das?
Wir geben es nicht wieder her.
Den Eindruck habe ich auch. Ihr seid schon ziemlich lange dabei, oder?
Ja, ja, ich küsse jetzt gerade nicht mehr ganz auf die Reihe, weil seit wann? Lang genug.
Na, was denn jetzt, fünf Jahre oder was? Also, ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass ihr überhaupt erst mal kräftig zuschlucken hattet an Gimp 2, also an der Version 2.0. Weil das wohl der größte Kraftakt war bisher, oder?
Na ja, da haben wir halt schon einiges auf die Beine gestellt. Gimp 2.0 war halt sozusagen der Schritt weg jetzt mal von diesem ursprünglichen Design von 1995. Und halt auch sehr, sehr viel von diesen ganzen Versionsnummern gedöhnt hat halt irgendwie tatsächlich mit Kompatibilität und Plugins und so weiter zu tun. Mit Gimp 2.0 haben wir halt ganz viel über Bord geworfen von dem, was da am Anfang mal irgendwie so entstanden ist und was man halt irgendwie immer noch weiter mit rumgetragen hat. Weil wenn wir das jetzt rausnehmen, dann funktionieren die ganzen alten Plugins nicht mehr. Und bei 2.0 haben wir halt den Schnitt gemacht und haben gesagt, so, die alten Plugins tun es einfach gar nicht mehr. Wir bauen das Ding zwar jetzt nicht komplett um. Es wird halt immer möglich sein, so ein altes Plugin oder ein frühes Skript irgendwie umzuschreiben und jemand, der ein bisschen weiß, was er da tut, der kriegt das halt hin. Relativ schnell auch. Aber hier ist einfach mal ein Schnitt und ab jetzt ist es 2.0. Und seitdem ist es Gimp 2. Und seitdem ist halt auch so eine Kompatibilität gewahrt. Also alle Plugins, die die Leute geschrieben haben für Gimp 2.0 oder Gimp 2.2, funktionieren halt einfach so, ohne dass man sie neu kompiliert oder irgendwas. Also einfach weiter benutzen.
Out of the Box, wie man das sich wünscht. Spielt Plugins so eine große Rolle? Kommt da der Großteil der Funktionalität aus Plugins oder ist eigentlich das Programm selbst die Quelle der eigentlichen Leistungsfähigkeit?
Gimp selber kommt ja schon mal mit einem ganzen Sammelsurium an Plugins. Und ein großer Teil der Funktionalität, würde ich schon sagen, steckt tatsächlich in diesen Plugins drin.
Das heißt, wenn man das bricht, dann wäre das schon fatal?
Na ja, gut, die Plugins, die wir quasi mitliefern, die könnten wir ja auch anpassen. Aber es gibt halt schon auch eine ganze Reihe Plugins da draußen, die entweder einfach jemand mal geschrieben hat, weil er es irgendwie brauchte und hat sie dann in ihre... Wir haben so eine Plugin-Registry, da kann man irgendwie nachgucken, gibt es vielleicht diesen Filter, gibt es diesen Effekt, kann den da runterladen. Es gibt aber halt auch Plugins, die wirklich so quasi eine eigene, kleine Community haben, wo zwei, drei Leute dran arbeiten, die regelmäßig neue Releases rausbringen und so. Wenn wir das alles in unserem, in GIMP selber machen würden, dann wäre das wahrscheinlich schon gar nicht mehr händelbar. Also ich finde es sehr wichtig, dass es hier eine Schnittstelle gibt, wo die Leute selber weitermachen können. Wir sozusagen die Grundlage bieten, hier ist Bildmanipulation und wenn ihr irgendwie einen coolen Filter habt, wenn ihr irgendwo gelesen habt, hier Algorithmus, dann kann man sich eben hinsetzen und kann Plugins schreiben, kann sich seine Aufgaben, die man viel zu oft machen muss, skripten und...
Was sind denn so die... Also ich meine, du hast ja gesagt, ihr wisst nicht, wie viele User ihr habt, das ist glaube ich klar, ich weiß auch nicht, wie viele Hörer ich habe. Aber ein bisschen was kriegt man ja schon mit. Wie würdest du denn so die Benutzerschaft von Gimp einschätzen? Also welche Aufgaben werden jetzt heutzutage mit der Software erledigt? Und vor allem vielleicht mal so mit deinen Worten, wofür taugt Gimp gut? Gibt ja immer diese, ist Gimp Photoshop? Ja, muss es dasselbe können? Kann es das Gleiche? Kann es mehr oder kann es nur was anderes? Also wie siehst du die Software derzeit so aufgestellt? Und was sind so die Entwicklungen, die da am meisten eine Rolle spielen in der Zeit? Jetzt wieder viele Fragen auf einmal. Also vielleicht erstmal, wer benutzt Gimp?
Naja, auch hier muss man natürlich ein bisschen raten, aber man kriegt es natürlich schon mit. Man hat halt irgendwie Mailing-Listen und Foren, wo man ja halt auch so ein bisschen guckt, was machen die Leute eigentlich damit, was wollen die Leute, und so ein bisschen zu gucken, wo sind die User-Wünsche. Und das kann man eigentlich sagen. Was viel gemacht wird, ist Digital-Fotografie. Vielleicht nicht unbedingt in dem High-End-Profi-Bereich, weil da werden dann ganz schnell auch kleinere Mängel oder Unzulänglichkeiten. Deutlich, da können wir ja vielleicht später nochmal darauf eingehen, ob wir jetzt mal hier dabei zu bleiben. Aber so für den üblichen Gebrauch, ich mache dieses Foto hier mal ein bisschen heller, ich schneide es mir zu, ich mache die roten Augen weg, justiere den Horizont gerade oder klone vielleicht auch mal jemand raus oder jemand rein. Dafür wird GIMP schon viel benutzt. Was auch sehr im Vordergrund steht, sind Webseiten. Die Leute machen sich ihre Homepages und die wollen da Grafik drauf haben. Und es gibt auch tatsächlich einige Leute, die das so im professionellen Webgrafikbereich schon machen. Das sind jetzt vielleicht nicht die ganz großen Webgrafikbüros, aber es gibt unheimlich viele Leute da draußen, die halt sich so ein bisschen Geld dazu verdienen, indem sie Webseiten designen. Und für die ist halt auch schon auch der Preis ausschlaggebend. Die wollen ja nicht quasi den Jahresverdienst in die Software stecken. Das ist halt ein bisschen Studenten-Nebenverdienst. Und für Web brauchst du keinen Hochfarbsupport mit 16 Bit Farbtiefe pro Kanal. CMYK ist auch kein Thema im Web.
Das unterstützt Gimp auch noch gar nicht. Oder ist das jetzt dabei, CMYK? Also das andere, also Farbmodelle, das ist das, worüber wir reden. RGB ist natürlich Standard. Das macht ja jeder Computerbildschirm. Da muss man das drin. Aber so diese Farbmischung für den Print, das ist ja immer so eine Diskussion.
Ja, ja, es wird rudimentär unterstützt. Also man muss da immer ein bisschen aufpassen. Also man kann jetzt nicht sagen, es würde gar nicht unterstützt werden. Gerade nicht mit 2.4. Da hat sich in der Richtung schon noch was getan. Aber Gimp editiert die, also speichert die Bilder immer noch in RGB. Das heißt, du kannst zwar ein CMYK Bild aufmachen, das wird dann aber konvertiert in RGB. Und das ist im Zweifel nicht das, was du willst. Wenn du wirklich nahe in der Druckstufe arbeitest, dann ist der übliche Workflow eigentlich schon der, dass sehr viel in RGB gearbeitet wird. Aber an irgendeinem Punkt geht man dann nach CMYK und breitet das Bild quasi wirklich für den Druck vor. Und Leute, die dann in dem Bereich der Druckvorstufe arbeiten, müssen halt auch dieses CMYK-Bild eventuell nochmal bearbeiten können. Da sieht man dann, dass kommt beim Drucker die falsche Farbe raus, dann gehst du nochmal rein und gehst in dieses farbseperierte Bild und bearbeitest es da. Es gibt tatsächlich auch Leute, die sagen, man fängt direkt so an und arbeitet halt von vorne rein, CMYK. Das ist eigentlich schon ein Ding, von dem die Leute sich langsamer herunterkommen. Das siehst du auch bei den professionellen Programmen, die nämlich immer mehr in Richtung RGB-Workflows optimieren. Weil das, was aus dem Scanner fällt, das, was aus deinem Digitalkamera fällt, das ist RGB.
Was der Bildschirm anzeigt.
Was der Bildschirm anzeigt, ist auch RGB. Und im Endeffekt geht es nachher nur darum, dass der Drucker möglichst das Gut wiedergibt. Das Beste, was du eigentlich machen kannst in dem Moment, ist, du definierst ganz klar, was ist das für ein RGB, was ich dir hier gebe? Ist das sRGB oder Adobe RGB? Es gibt Farbprofile, mit denen man genau beschreiben kann, was ist genau mein Farbraum. Und dann lässt du das den Drucker machen. Weil der weiß genau, welches Papier liegt da drin, welche Tinten habe ich eingekauft und in diesen Drucker gelegt. Wie muss ich jetzt diese Farbinformation, von der ich genau weiß, diese Farbe soll so aussehen? Wie muss ich das jetzt aufteilen in die Druckfarben, damit es dann möglichst dann auch so aussieht?
Das heißt, dieser Zwang, eine Software zu haben, die so einen für den Druck optimierten Farbraum auf dem Bildschirm simuliert, den siehst du nicht mehr so groß.
Den sehe ich in vielen Bereichen nicht mehr so groß.
Ja, ich meine, diese ganzen Farbraummodelle ist ja auch so eine Entwicklung der letzten Jahre. Das gab es ja auch lange Zeit nicht. Also, ich weiß nicht, wo das losging.
Als das losging, hat das keinen interessiert.
Genau, weil es bedarf ja auch sozusagen einer vollständig geschlossenen Kette. Also, wie du schon gesagt hast, Scanner müssen das von vornherein berücksichtigen. Also jedes Mal, wenn ein Bild von einem Gerät zum nächsten weitergeschoben wird, muss diese volle Information erhalten bleiben. Und wie macht das Gimp? Also, da ist jetzt sozusagen so ein Farbraummodell. Jeder Pixel wird dann immer in so einem Referenz-Farbraum gespeichert, die Farbe, oder wie?
Gimp benutzt intern immer noch eigentlich sRGB grundsätzlich. So, als Farbraum.
Was ist denn das sRGB? Ist da noch eine vierte Farbe S? Oder ist das Standard?
Nee, das ist im Prinzip ein RGB-Modell, was sehr nah an dem liegt, was die Monitore darstellen. Das heißt, hier ist irgendwie der Gamma-Wert definiert. Das ist der Verlauf vom hellen nach dunklen. Und sRGB ist das, was irgendwann standardisiert wurde als Farbraum für Web-Grafiken. Weil das ist, was man unkorrigiert auf den Monitor wirft, und dann sieht es so aus. Weil Gimp eigentlich immer noch komplett unkorrigiert arbeitet, der Farbraum ist eigentlich sRGB. Was wir jetzt gemacht haben in 2.4 ist, wir haben Farbmanagement insoweit eingebaut, dass du Farbprofile an Dateien anhängen kannst, dass er auch Farbprofile, die an Dateien schon angehängt sind, respektiert und entweder die anbietet, das umzuwandeln, damit es dann wirklich sRGB ist, in dem du arbeitest. Du kannst aber auch sagen, ich lasse das, so wie es ist, und es wird nur bei der Ansicht umgewandelt. Das heißt, Adobe RGB benutzen viele Leute zum Beispiel gerne, weil sie sagen, sie können da einen etwas breiteren Farbraum drin abbilden. Das heißt nicht, dass du jetzt plötzlich auf deinem Monitor irgendwelche Farben sehen könntest, die du vorher nicht sehen konntest. Aber es könnte sein, dass du Farben nachher drucken kannst, die du vielleicht vorher so nicht mehr hättest, Farbschattierungen, die du so in sRGB nicht mehr hättest darstellen können. Und man kann jetzt halt diese Farbprofile insofern berücksichtigen, dass er dir die Bildschirmdarstellung korrigiert. Das heißt, das Ding ist Adobe RGB und er wandelt es so um, dass es für den Monitor, entweder hast du ein Monitor-Profil auch und hast einen farbkalibrierten Monitor, damit es auch berücksichtigt, oder es wird im angenommenen Monitor sRGB.
Das heißt, das ist jetzt auch eine, hast du ja schon gesagt, das hat sich jetzt bei dem aktuellen Release 2.4 verbessert? Gab es vorher schon so ein bisschen und jetzt ist es irgendwie besser?
Es gab es eigentlich vorher gar nicht.
Ach so, jetzt ist es neu.
Es ist wirklich neu.
Ah, okay. Gut, das heißt, da hätten wir ja schon mal ein neues Feature der Version 2.4. Gibt es denn noch andere bahnbrechende Entwicklungen in 2.4, von denen man unbedingt Kenntnis haben sollte?
Was wir gemacht haben, was ich vorhin schon mal erwähnt habe, wir haben so ein paar Tools komplett umgebaut. Und zwar Tools, die man eigentlich andauernd verwendet, nämlich die Selektionstools, um rechteckige Selektionen, Ellipsen und Kreise und so zu machen. Das war halt schon immer eigentlich so ein bisschen Dorn im Auge. Ich ziehe da irgendwie meinen Rechteck auf und dann habe ich mich um einen Pixel vertan. Und wieso kann ich das jetzt nicht einfach mal so an der Ecke packen und wieder zurecht schieben?
Das heißt, wir sind jetzt sozusagen resizable.
Genau, das ist jetzt resizable. Und wir haben den gleichen Code auch gleich noch für das Zuschneiden-Werkzeug, das Scrop Tool, verwendet, sodass da jetzt quasi dasselbe User Interface auch gleich als Look and Feel verwendet wird. Und das ist sehr gut angekommen. Die Leute sagen ja echt so, das fühlt sich toll an. Warum war das nicht schon immer so? Das fühlt sich so vom ersten Moment an, als hätte es schon immer so sein müssen. Da hat sich tatsächlich jetzt mal ausgezahlt, dass wir angefangen haben, nicht mehr nur einfach Leute, die irgendwas programmieren, auch das User Interface und User Interaction Design machen zu lassen, sondern wir haben hier das erste Mal im 2004er Entwicklungszeitraum Usability-Leute, Leute, die auch professionell oder schon länger dabei sind, wirklich User Interface Design zu machen, mit Entwicklern zusammenzubringen. Das heißt, sie sagen, hier ist ein Problem und wir wollen es irgendwie neu machen. Bisher lief es dann so, dass irgendjemand gesagt hat, ich habe da eine grobe Vorstellung, wie so etwas aussehen müsste und ich hacke das mal. Dann wurde das halt irgendwie gehackt. Wenn das stabil war und wir der Meinung waren, dass es vielleicht besser ist, dann wurde das halt so gemacht. Da fehlt dann aber schon dieses professionelle Rangehen, dass man erst mal sagt, was will denn der User eigentlich machen? Hat sich schon mal jemand überlegt, wofür man dieses Tool überhaupt benutzt? Hat schon mal jemand gefragt, hat sich mal ein paar Workflows aufgeschrieben und dann mal geguckt, wie klappt das mit dem jetzigen Verhalten? Wo sind die Probleme? Dann fängt man an und überlegt sich, wie löst man das jetzt? Und wenn man dann so eine Lösung gefunden hat, dann muss man die halt irgendwie gegen diese ganzen Workflows wieder abklopfen. Dann muss man diese ganzen Szenarien, die man sich vorher ausgemalt hat, sich wieder angucken und gucken, klappt das jetzt immer noch? Kann ich das, was ich vorher damit gegen immer noch tun? Funktioniert das neue Ding jetzt besser? Und das ist hier halt tatsächlich mal passiert.
Habt ihr das dann über das Netz gemacht oder habt ihr euch dazu in ReLive getroffen? Das erscheint mir ja nun wirklich eine Interaktion zu sein, die man so in E-Mail und Chats nicht so ohne Weiteres rüberbringen kann.
Beides. Beides. Es hat halt tatsächlich zum großen Teil online stattgefunden und findet auch immer noch statt. Aber es hat halt auch Treffen gegeben.
Das heißt, ihr macht auch regelmäßig Entwicklertreffen?
Wir machen eigentlich seit 1999, auf dem Camp haben wir quasi damit angefangen.
Auf dem ersten Camp, genau.
Und haben also das erste Gimp-Entwicklermeeting gemacht, damals noch zu viert oder so. Was nicht heißt, dass es damals nur vier Entwickler gab, aber es waren halt um vier Grad zufällig vier Leute, die sich da zusammengefunden haben.
Aber ein Anfang war gemacht. Und auf dem zweiten Chaos-Communication-Camp gab es ja dann schon etwas größeres Treffen.
Da waren... Ich weiß gar nicht, wie viele, genau, Leute, es waren knapp 20 waren schon irgendwie da.
Das ist ja schon eine ganze Menge, finde ich eigentlich, für so ein Programm, wo die Leute ja auch, keine Ahnung, wo die überall sitzen. Wo sind denn so die Entwickler? Wo wird denn so mitgehackt am Gimp? Weltweit, kann man da sagen?
Weltweit, kann man eigentlich sagen. Also inzwischen ist der Schwerpunkt doch eher in Europa zu finden. Viele Deutsche, Franzosen, Belgier.
Liegt das an irgendwas, oder ist das einfach nur so?
Ist das einfach so.
Ich meine, das ist ja ganz interessant. Die Software wurde in den USA gestartet. Und rutscht so über die Jahre langsam über den Teich. Und wird jetzt hier weiterentwickelt. Okay, aber auf jeden Fall macht die Sache natürlich einfacher, wenn man dann hier mal ein Treffen... Ich nehme mal an, die ganzen Entwicklertreffen waren dann auch alle in Europa.
Ja, letztes Jahr gab es tatsächlich das erste Mal ein außereuropäisches Treffen in Kanada. Was daran liegt, ist inzwischen aus dem Gimp-Entwicklertreffen, die so aus diesem ersten Treffen auf dem Camp quasi hervorging, zwischen so groß geworden sind, dass es schon gar kein reines Gimp-Treffen mehr ist, sondern wir machen jetzt seit zwei Jahren das sogenannte Libre Graphics Meeting. Das heißt, da treffen sich nicht nur die Gimp-Entwickler, sondern auch die Entwickler von anderen freien Programmen, die sich in irgendeiner Weise mit Grafik auseinandersetzen.
Was gibt es da noch?
Vektorzeichen-Programme, Inkscape ist vertreten. Tatsächlich auch die Konkurrenz aus dem KDE-Lager Krita war letztes Mal mit zwei Leuten vertreten. Auf den letzten Treffen war ich leider selber nicht.
Also Konkurrenz in Anführungsstriche. Ich habe die Anführungsstriche gerade gesehen.
Die sieht man natürlich nicht.
Es ist nicht wirklich, dass wir das als eine Konkurrenz ansehen. Also es konkurriert sicherlich um User.
Es konkurriert schon natürlich so ein bisschen.
Aber das kann nur gut sein.
Aber es ist halt nur gut eigentlich. Das spart an, weil du siehst halt auch mal, man kann es auch anders machen. Vielleicht sagt man, das gefällt mir aber nicht, wie die das machen. Aber manchmal sagt man auch, eigentlich haben sie aber auch recht. So ist es ja eigentlich doch viel besser. Und vielleicht sollten wir uns auch mal überlegen, ob wir es nicht doch auch so oder so ähnlich oder so machen.
Okay.
Das ist schon ganz gut. Krita ist tatsächlich noch recht jung in der Entwicklung. Das macht schnelle Fortschritte, steckt, wenn ich das richtig beurteile, tatsächlich so ein bisschen in der Hand von ein, zwei Entwicklern, was auch sehr gut sein kann. Weil man natürlich dann viel zielorientierter arbeiten kann und sich gar nicht mit so vielen Leuten rumschlagen muss. Klingt jetzt so, als wären es unglaublich viele Gimp-Entwickler. So ist es ja nur auch.
Ja, aber du hast ja schon anklingen lassen, dass auch so die Koordinierung eine ganze Menge Zeit frisst, weil man natürlich dann auch mit den Charakteren und Persönlichkeiten sich wahrscheinlich herumschlagen muss. Das ist sicherlich auch nicht immer ein Spaß. Jetzt wollte ich nochmal kurz, bevor uns das wieder entgleitet, du hast ja gesagt, ihr habt jetzt bei der Version 2.4 Usability-Leute mit reingebracht. Ist das jetzt Open Usability das Projekt?
Das ist so ein bisschen auch aus der Open Usability-Ecke gekommen. Da gab es unter anderem letztes Jahr im Winter so etwas Ähnliches wie den Google Summer of Code. Das heißt, hier gab es ein gesponsertes Projekt für Studenten, aber eben diesmal nicht für Informatik-Studenten, sondern für Studenten, die sich mit Usability befassen und Usability studieren.
Da gibt es schon einen Studiengang für?
Da gibt es Studiengänge für, ja ja, ich frage mich nicht, wie das genau heißt. Also man kann sich zumindest in einer Fachrichtung darauf spezialisieren.
Ich denke auch, dass ein Express-Podcast zu dem Thema Usability ist, ohnehin noch mal fällig.
Das war tatsächlich ein Projekt von Open Usability. Und da wurde damals jemand gesucht, der einfach mal zusammen mit Peter Sikking hier aus Berlin eine Evaluation von Gimp macht. Und die sind dann halt zu uns gekommen und haben gesagt, so jetzt wollen wir mal von den Entwicklern hören, was ist denn eigentlich so die Vision? Wo wollt ihr eigentlich hin? Was ist denn eigentlich das, wenn ihr jetzt mal ganz viel Zeit und Geld oder was auch immer oder einfach nur Zeit und Leute hättet? Wo ist euer Ziel? Wo wollt ihr in fünf Jahren irgendwie mit dem Programm sein? Und da haben wir uns mal so ein bisschen zusammengesetzt, so ein Wochenende lang und haben so ein bisschen auch nicht nur aus der Entwicklerecke, sondern so ein bisschen aus der Ecke von Leuten, die Dokumentation schreiben und sich viel mit Usern auseinandersetzen. Mal so überlegt, was wollen wir eigentlich und wo sind die User-Szenarien, die wir unterstützen wollen und die Workflows und den ganzen Kram. Und mit dieser Information sind dann Peter und Camilla, eine Studentin aus Polen, die quasi diese Ausschreibung gewonnen hat und ausgewählt wurde, diese Evaluation zu machen. Sie haben sich jetzt hingesetzt und haben fast ein halbes Jahr lang doch recht intensiv das ganze Programm analysiert.
Ein Jahr lang?
Ein halbes Jahr lang. Wir haben natürlich nicht den ganzen Tag daran gearbeitet. Ich weiß, schon so 10 bis 20 Stunden die Woche, da ist wirklich viel Arbeit reingeflassen. Das Ganze ist auch online, das kann man sich angucken. Und der nächste Schritt ist jetzt eigentlich so da. Den Link gibst du mir dann nachher.
Genau, hier mal wieder mal der Standard-Hinweis, Links zur Sendung. Fast alles, was hier erwähnt wird, findet ihr auf Chaosradio CCCD auf der begleitenden Seite zur Sendung. Da bemühe ich mich immer, alles schön zu verlinken. So auch dann dieser Link. Und das kam dann dabei raus. Also die haben sozusagen einmal so eine Bestandsaufnahme gemacht.
Die haben einmal so eine Bestandsaufnahme gemacht. Deswegen kann man das auch nur ganz schwer jetzt in zwei Sätzen zusammenfassen. Aber die haben halt an ganz vielen Ecken aufgezeigt, wo sind Probleme, wo steht quasi das User Interface dem User ein bisschen im Weg. Wo müsste man mal ganz anders ran? Und ausgehend von der Information kann man jetzt hingehen und kann neue Features planen und keine Änderungen im User Interface planen. Das haben wir mit den Tools in 2.4, mit den wenigen, die da geändert wurden, sozusagen das erste Mal mal gemacht. Das heißt, die sind implementiert worden nach einer Spezifikation, die vor allen Dingen von Peter gemacht wurde. Das heißt, der hat genau aufgeschrieben, wenn der User dahin klickt, dann soll das passieren und hat sich überlegt, wie kriegt man das hin mit den verschiedenen Modifier-Tasten des Mannes.
Dass es auch konsistent ist?
Dass es konsistent ist, dass es mit den anderen Tools konsistent ist, dass das wirklich auch funktioniert, dass die Bereiche, wo man mit der Maus draufklickt, groß sind und klar sind und dass das Ding sich vorhersehbar verhält und so. Da ist unheimlich viel Detailwissen drin, was einem Entwickler oft fehlt oder wo er einfach nicht dran denkt.
Weil das einfach nicht so sein Thema ist?
Weil das nicht so sein Thema ist. Oder wo er vielleicht auch dran denkt, wo er aber nicht wirklich die Entscheidung treffen kann. Wo er dann im Prinzip den ganzen Abend damit verbringt, sich zu überlegen, mach ich es jetzt so oder mach ich es jetzt so. Wo er eigentlich den ganzen Abend hacken wollte. Er will eigentlich diesen Code schreiben. Also so eine Spezifikation ist manchmal wirklich eine Gnade. Weil du hast einfach da ein Dokument liegen. Und wenn es eine Frage gibt, dann guckst du da rein. Was hier jetzt auch noch toll war, dass Peter halt wirklich auch für Rückfragen immer da war. Der ist dann zur Not vielleicht auch live im IRC-Channel. Und du hast eine Frage. Dann wird das mal kurz durchdiskutiert. Und dann wird die Speck abgedatet im Netz. Dann ist sofort die neue Version da. Wir haben also ein Wiki geschaffen für, was nicht öffentlich ist, sondern nur sozusagen für die User Interface Experten offen ist. Da entstehen so die Spezifikationen. Und da werden wir halt auch jetzt für die nächste Version.
Das heißt, das war eine wirkliche Hilfe. Das hat wirklich was gebracht. Und das wäre jetzt auch etwas, was du anderen Anwendungsentwicklern so ohne Weiteres uneingeschränkt empfehlen würdest?
Ich muss sagen, es kommt immer so ein bisschen drauf an, wie komplex das Ganze halt auch ist. Du brauchst nicht für jeden Dialog ein User Interface Experten. Aber manchmal hilft es schon ungemein. Vor allem, halt einfach mal noch eine zweite Meinung dazu zu haben. Was viele Leute tun, wenn sie vor den Problemen stehen, sie bloggen einfach da drüber, machen ein paar Screenshots, und dann schauen sie mal, was so kommt.
Das machst du ja jetzt auch.
Das mache ich schon auch hin und wieder mal.
Selten.
Selten, sollte ich auch mal wieder öfters tun. Werde ich auch jetzt wieder öfters tun, weil dir jetzt auch mal wieder neue Entwicklungen ansteht. Das ist halt so ein bisschen langweilig, wenn du irgendwie darüber bloggst, dass du die letzten zwei Monate lang nur die Bugs gefixed hast, die noch auf dem Milestone standen. Und dass wir jetzt von 27 Bugs auf dem Milestone auf sieben runter sind.
Ich finde das nicht langweilig.
Für mich war das toll, weil es war halt wirklich so, dass man ein Jahr lang fast nichts anderes gemacht hat, außer halt Bugs gefixed. Es ist zu versuchen, diese Zahl von Fehlern, die noch unbedingt gefixed werden müssen, soweit zu verringern, dass man irgendwann sagen kann, na gut, und die letzten drei, die sind uns jetzt auch egal. Wir machen jetzt das Release.
Wie viele habt ihr da wegloppen müssen? Ich meine, wie lange ist so? Also, ihr benutzt einen Bug-Tracker. Was benutzt ihr da technisch?
Wir benutzen Bugzilla, weil wir das von GNOME Org benutzen. Wir benutzen einiges so an Infrastruktur, was auf den GNOME-Servern läuft.
Und wie viele Fehler waren da so drin?
Wir haben zurzeit offene Bug-Reports. Das sind dann inklusive Verbesserungsvorschläge, sind zurzeit 550.
550. Und wenn man die Verbesserungsvorschläge rausnimmt, wie viele sind es dann?
50. Es sind schon noch 200 oder so.
Das meiste sind Verbesserungsvorschläge?
Das allermeiste sind doch Verbesserungsvorschläge. Ich weiß es wirklich gar nicht genau. Vielleicht sind es sogar noch wesentlich weniger als die 200. Aber es sind weniger Bugs. Wenn uns jemand einen Crash zeigt, kann man einfach nicht auf sich sitzen lassen. Das Programm darf nicht abstürzen. Wenn ein Crash-Report kommt, der in irgendeiner Weise reproduzierbar ist, dann ist es normalerweise eine Sache von Stunden oder wenigen Tagen, bis er gefixt ist. Bis er beim User gefixt ist, dauert das noch mal ein paar Wochen, weil wir dann auch nicht für jeden Crash gleich wieder einen Bug-Fix-Release machen. Aber die Anforderung ist schon recht hoch. Was sicher auch ein Grund ist, warum Gimp so beliebt ist.
Dass es so stabil ist?
Es werden sicher jetzt einige Leute schreien bei mir, stürze es aber immer ab. Aber meine Erfahrung ist, dass diese Abstürze meist systembedingt sind. Gerade auf der Windows-Plattform hatten wir sehr viele Probleme mit Stabilität, die aber einfach aus dem GTK-Port stammen. Daraus bedingte sich, dass es einfach viel zu wenig Unterstützung aus der Windows-Welt gibt. Die Windows-User wollen zwar gerne auch freie Software benutzen, genau wie auch die Mac OS X-User. Das ist eigentlich ähnlich. Die sind auch sehr interessiert daran. Aber es kommt wenig zurück aus dem Bereich.
Weil da nicht so viele Entwickler sind?
Vielleicht auch, weil die Hürde natürlich viel größer ist. Wir entwickeln das Programm. Also eigentlich alle Entwickler entwickeln das unter Linux. Natürlich ist dann jetzt auch das ganze Ding darauf abgestimmt. Die Tools, die verwendet werden, sind einfach so die Standardentwickler-Tools auf einem Unix-System. Wenn du das unter Windows machen willst, dann musst du dir erstmal so ein Unix-Entwicklungssystem unter Windows installieren. Das geht, aber das schreckt ab. Allerdings bin ich mir nicht so sicher, wenn man jetzt irgendwie Microsoft Visual C++-Project-Files einchecken würde, ob das in irgendeiner Weise was daran ändern würde.
Ja gut, also Open Source Development ist im Windows-Bereich ganz offensichtlich nicht so stark ausgeprägt wie bei Linux. Von daher ist es schwierig. Mit Mac ist es da nicht anders, hast du ja schon gesagt. Es ist nicht wirklich etwas Neues oder Seltenes, aber gerade für Grafik-Software hat man es vor allem mit einem großen Benutzerschad zu tun. Was natürlich ein großes Problem ist, oder vielleicht ist es auch keins, muss ich jetzt auch noch mal fragen. Du hast ja schon gesagt, Gimp hat mal angefangen und hat sich als erstes sein eigenes User Interface Toolkit mitgeboren, weil da war halt noch nichts. Später wurde das dann ausgegliedert, ist zu GTK geworden und ist ja dann auch die Basis von dem, was GNOME heutzutage ausmacht. Also einen vollständigen Desktop. Diese Unterscheidungen sind manchmal ein bisschen schwierig zu machen. Also eine vollständige Umgebung, die einem versucht, alles zu bieten, was man so braucht. Jetzt läuft aber Gimp nicht nur unter GNOME, oder?
Nee, der gleiche Code übersetzt halt auch auf quasi mehr oder weniger allen, was man so an Plattformen heutzutage da draußen hat. So was an PCs ist. Ich glaube nicht, dass es da noch irgendwas Nennenswertes gibt, wo man Gimp nicht drauf übersetzt kriegt. Für Linux bedeutet das halt, dass es kann GNOME sein, es kann irgendwie ein KDE sein, was der User vor sich hat. Viele haben auch noch Enlightment und soll sogar noch FVW im User geben. Also verschiedene Umgebungen, mit denen das Programm klarkommen muss. Was wir hier machen, ist so ein bisschen, dass wir dieses Cross-Plattform-Ding von GTK machen. Also alles ist auf allen Plattformen gleich. Das heißt, ein Gimp auf dem Mac sieht eigentlich so aus, wie ein Gimp auf einem GNOME-Desktop, wie auf einem KDE-Desktop, wie unter Windows. Es wird ein bisschen was gemacht, es wird ein bisschen geteamt. Dann sehen vielleicht irgendwie die Knöpfe von der Farbe her ein bisschen aus wie die nativen von dem Betriebssystem, wie sozusagen alle anderen Programme auf dem Ding. Aber es ist schon überall so ein bisschen so ein Fremdkörper, außer unter GNOME, weil da passt es einfach rein. Da ist halt alles GTK. Da findest du überall den gleichen Dateiauswahl-Dialog.
Also da ist es sozusagen zu Hause.
Da wird immer der gleiche Drucker-Dialog benutzt.
Das heißt, schon auf dem KDE-System wirkt es ein bisschen anders?
Ja, es hat Bestrebungen gegeben in letzter Zeit, und die gibt es auch immer noch, da zumindest ein paar technische Hürden aus dem Weg zu schaffen, dass die Programme einfach wirklich gut funktionieren. Da gibt es diese Free Desktop-Initiative, wo Standards geschaffen werden, die von den GNOME und KDE-Leuten unterstützt werden. Und da halten wir uns auch dran, soweit es geht. Aber das sind natürlich Standards, die Microsoft und Apple auch herzlich wenig interessieren. Und um eine wirkliche Zusammenarbeit da auf allen Plattformen zu erreichen, da gibt es wahrscheinlich überhaupt kein Interesse daran.
Ja, das kann ich mir auch nicht vorstellen, weil die Unterschiede sind ja auch teilweise extrem. Und man fängt ja schon damit an, dass man ja unter Linux immer noch das uralte X-Windows verwendet. Wie macht ihr das dann?
Na ja, das X-Windows unter Linux ist ja auch nicht mehr uralt. Das entwickelt sich ja auch ständig weiter. Und es ist halt einfach das Fenstersystem, das da benutzt wird.
Ja gut, aber inwieweit seid ihr davon abhängig? Also unter Windows gibt es ja kein X.
GTK selber hat schon von vornherein so eine Abstraktionsschicht gehabt, wo sie quasi das X vor dem Applikationseinwender verbergen. Das heißt, wenn man ein Programm mit GTK schreibt, sieht man eigentlich das X-Windowsystem nicht. Und deshalb war es halt auch möglich, das dann irgendwann mal auf Windows zu portieren, was schon recht früh passiert ist. Und jetzt im letzten ein, zwei Jahren gab es Bestrebungen, das Ganze auf Mac OS X zu portieren. Und was ich so gehört habe, ist das wohl inzwischen auch benutzbar. Das war noch so ein bisschen in den Kinderschulen, vielleicht noch nicht unbedingt was für jeden. Aber man kann damit wohl arbeiten. Also es gibt inzwischen auch Bineries für GIMP 2.4, die ohne den X-Server auf dem Mac laufen. Und wir haben sogar ein bisschen mac-spezifischen Code eingebaut in 2.4, sodass wir eine Menüleiste bekommen, wie der Mac-User das gewohnt ist, die eben oben am Bildschirmrand hängt und eine Menüleiste für das ganze GIMP ist.
Aber für so eine richtig native Anwendung, da dauert das halt noch. Das heißt, man braucht auf dem Mac... Braucht man jetzt noch das X-Windows? Nein, du brauchst das X-Windows.
Wenn du ein bisschen zu Experimenten bereit bist, dann brauchst du es nicht mehr. Ich gehe davon aus, dass es wahrscheinlich noch bis zur nächsten Version dauern wird, bis es so richtig benutzbar ist und bis es wirklich dann auch einen Installer gibt, den jeder User einfach in seinen Finder zieht und an das GIMP benutzt. Auch dann wird es natürlich keine wirklich 100%-native Anwendung sein, aber ich denke, wenn wir so Sachen wie Track & Drop noch in den Griff kriegen, dann fühlt sich das schon ganz gut an.
Okay, wir waren vorhin so ein bisschen, wir springen ein wenig, aber wir kommen immer wieder zurück zu den guten Sachen. Wir waren so ein bisschen bei den Features, die jetzt in der neuen Version mit reingekommen sind. Also Usability haben wir nun ausführlich besprochen, auch die Sache mit dem Farbraum. Gibt es noch weitere oder waren das jetzt so die wesentlichen Dinge, mit denen sich die Version schmückt?
Es sind unglaublich viele, viele kleine Dinge. Wir haben noch ein paar schicke neue Tools. Wir haben z.B. ein perspektivenfisches Stempelwerkzeug. Das ist ziemlich abgefahren eigentlich, weil damit kann man schöne Sachen machen, wenn du üblicherweise Dinge in einem Bild verdoppeln willst oder von der einen Stelle an die andere bringst. Dann benutzt du das Stempelwerkzeug. Damit kann man quasi von der einen Stelle auf die andere was abpinseln. Hat aber dann oft das Problem, dass du etwas dahinten hier vorne haben willst. Du musst es während des Stempels auch vergrößern. Mit dem Tool machst du das automatisch. Du legst deine Ebene in das Bild rein und erklärst, wie die Perspektive an der Stelle ist.
man baut sich eine Hilfslinie und sagt, hier ist der Tunnel.
Du kannst sagen, ich will diesen Gullideckel auf der Straße nach dahinten verlegen. Dann deutest du an, wie die Straße aussieht. Und kannst dann einfach sagen, das ist der Quellpunkt, von dem ich kopieren will. Und kannst dann einfach mit einem Pinsel weiter hinten. Und der skaliert das gleich automatisch dahin. Und nimmt gleich auch die... Wenn du eine Kopfsteinpflaster hast, wird das hinten entsprechend kleiner.
Wer hat das gehackt?
Wer war denn das jetzt wieder? Das war tatsächlich Teil von Google Summer of Code Projekt. Und der Student war, wie das dann so oft ist, dann danach auch wieder zu beschäftigt, um weiter dabei zu bleiben.
Weil er dann gleich von Google aufgekauft wurde, wahrscheinlich. Meine eigentliche Frage wäre jetzt gewesen, was war jetzt die Triebfehler dafür? War das etwas, was er selber schon immer mal haben wollte? Oder war das dann eine von diesen 350 Feature-Requests, die im Bugtracker sind?
Wir haben für das Google Summer of Code Projekt tatsächlich uns ein paar besonders schicke Feature-Requests sozusagen rausgesucht. Und da hat er jetzt so gesagt, das wäre schon wirklich schön, wenn man das mal hätte. Aber da müsste sich ja jetzt auch wirklich mal jemand hinsetzen und dran eine längere Zeit dran haken. Und das hat eigentlich auch ganz gut funktioniert. Wir hatten letztes Jahr leider haben wir es irgendwie nicht geschafft. Das hat auch noch keiner herausgefunden, warum uns Google nicht mochte letztes Jahr. Ich glaube, sie haben sehr viele neue Projekte mal dazugenommen und ein bisschen versucht, von den alten großen Projekten so ein bisschen wegzukommen. Aber im Jahr davor hatten wir, glaube ich, sieben Studenten, von denen dann auch fünf das so mehr oder weniger zu Ende gebracht haben. Das ist jetzt leider noch nicht alles wirklich im Release drin. Wir haben noch so ein, zwei Features, die mehr oder weniger halbfertig in Branches liegen. Und da werden wir noch mal gucken, was wir mit denen für 2.6 machen. Da müssen jetzt sozusagen mal nochmal die User Interface Leute drüber.
2.6 ist jetzt sozusagen das nächste große Ziel. Ihr habt da so diese Versionsnummern-Schematik von Linux übernommen, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Also so richtige Releases haben immer eine gerade Zahl.
Genau, ja. Das, was Linux jetzt nicht mehr macht, aber...
Ja, machen sie gar nicht mehr.
Nee, da ist Linux jetzt noch viel komplizierter, das Versioning Schema. Aber bei uns ist das tatsächlich immer noch so.
Wäre das vielleicht auch ein Thema für eine eigene Sendung?
Das 2 vorne ist sozusagen so, das ist immer noch Gimp 2 und wir sind immer noch kompatibel. Und wenn wir jetzt instabile Snapshots machen, dann werden die 2.5 irgendwas heißen. Und irgendwann, diesmal nicht erst wieder in mehreren Jahren, soll es dann 2.6 geben.
Famous Last Words.
Ich habe das letzte Mal auch schon gesagt, dass wir 2.4 kürzer machen werden. Aber diesmal ist es tatsächlich so, dass wir jetzt die letzten zwei Wochen uns ganz ernsthaft auf der Mailing-Liste mit Roadmap auseinandergesetzt haben. Also quasi gesammelt haben, was sind denn so die Dinge, die ihr gerne hacken wollt in nächster Zeit? Was ist das, was wir unbedingt machen müssen, um weiterzukommen, um unserer Vision irgendwie näherzukommen? Und was können wir davon schaffen? Was lässt sich in 6 Monaten verwirklichen? Weil wir wollen einfach davon wegkommen, dass so viele kleine Verbesserungen, die ständig überall gemacht werden, dann immer 2 Jahre lang irgendwo brach liegen, bis sie dann endlich mal beim User ankommen. Und ich denke, wir können eigentlich schneller entwickeln, wenn wir viele kleine Release-Zyklen machen. Wenn wir versuchen, innerhalb von 6 Monaten sowas durchzuziehen. Das heißt, im Endeffekt, du hast 1-2 Monate Zeit, das ein bisschen zu planen. Wenn das nicht schon vorher irgendwie mal so durch das UI-Team durch ist und die quasi ihre Speck schon auf dem Tisch liegen haben, dann kannst du das 1-2 Monate lang programmieren und dann wird das stabilisiert und dann musst du es raus.
Ist also jetzt im Wesentlichen die Aufgabe der Maintainer? Also ist das jetzt, seit ihr da jetzt im Wesentlichen gefragt, ist das so eure Aufgabe, zu sagen, hier, ich schwing jetzt den harten Hammer und in 6 Monaten, tapp, tapp, tapp, hat das hier alles mal schön auf dem Server zu liegen und bloß keine Spielereien, meine Freunde?
Ja, das ist tatsächlich dann so die Aufgabe. Also ich hab gedacht, diesmal ziehe ich das quasi mal durch. Dann machen wir jetzt mal so wirklich den kleinen Diktator so und sagen, jetzt wird das so gemacht. Und bisher kommt das aber auch ganz gut an. Ich hab eigentlich sonst immer sehr auch den Spaß am Programmieren im Vordergrund stehen gehabt. Und ich denke halt, wenn jemand mir quasi vorschreibt, was ich jetzt genau machen muss und wann ich es abzugeben hab, dann ist das so ein bisschen wie bei der Arbeit.
Was ist denn der Spaß? Ich meine, du benutzt ja Gimp selber eigentlich gar nicht. Du schreibst ein Programm, was du nicht benutzt. Das ist ja eigentlich selten im Open Source Bereich. Meistens ist es so, die Leute brauchen irgendwas und dann hacken sie sich das. Deswegen gibt es unzählige Web-Server und was nicht alles. Weil die Systemadministratoren das natürlich auch als solches benutzen. Aber so eine Anwendungssoftware ist ja eine ganz andere Geschichte. Bildbearbeitung, hast du ja schon gesagt, ist nicht so dein Ding.
Heißt nicht, dass ich das nicht schon auch benutze, klar.
Selbstverständlich wirst du irgendwann dein Programm auch schon mal benutzen, aber du bist ja jetzt nicht in deinem richtigen Leben auch Programmierer. Du bist ja Coder und bist ja jetzt nicht ein programmierbegabter Grafiker. Der hat sich sein Wunderwerkzeug geschaffen.
Was einfach Spaß macht, ist Software zu schaffen, mit der man mit den Leute wirklich arbeiten kann und auch Dinge schaffen. Ich bewundere halt schon sehr die Kreativität von Leuten, die mit solchen Programmen auch schöne Sachen oder abgefahrene Sachen machen können. Interessiere mich sehr für die Arbeitsweisen und auch die Technik dahinter. Die Bildbearbeitung fasziniert mich schon, nur weil ich das nicht die ganze Zeit an meinen Fotos rumschraube. Interessiert mich doch sehr, was da so passiert und wie das geht. Auch Algorithmen sind eine interessante Sache.
Also wie man die ganzen Probleme dann auch konkret technisch löst.
Das ist natürlich auch etwas, was ich so ein bisschen entdeckt habe in den letzten Jahren, was sehr interessant war. Zwischendurch ist mir so ein bisschen abgehebt, aber eine Zeit lang habe ich sehr viel an diesen Usability Meetings teilgenommen, die wir hier in Berlin regelmäßig haben.
Da kam was bei rüber.
Da kam schon was bei rüber. Man lernt halt sehr viel besser, wie man an so etwas rangeht.
Kann man das irgendwie zusammenfassen, wie man an so etwas rangeht?
Naja, der Punkt ist, als Gimp-Entainer wirst du ständig mit Feature-Requests konfrontiert. Und zwar läuft es meistens so, die User kommen an und sagen, ihr müsst es so und so machen. Da gibt es dann irgendwie die einen, die sagen, ihr müsst es so und so machen, weil Photoshop das so macht. Oder die sagen halt irgendwie, weil ich das halt so, für mich wäre das super. Und das ist dann unheimlich schwer, dem zu begegnen, weil die Herangehensweise ist natürlich nicht die, dass man dem einen User jetzt irgendwie seinen Feature jetzt auf den Leib schneidet. Weil du musst natürlich eigentlich viel mehr gucken, was will der eigentlich erreichen. Der sagt mir jetzt, macht das so und so. Aber eigentlich ist das doch was ganz anderes. Der hat ein Problem. Also er hat eine Aufgabe, will die lösen, und irgendwie klappt das so nicht. Das User Interface ist ihm irgendwie im Weg, und er will eigentlich nur ein bestimmtes Problem lösen. Du musst so ein bisschen mehr die User dazu kriegen, dass sie dir erzählen, was sie eigentlich machen. Was machst du eigentlich den ganzen Tag mit dem Programm? Oder wenn du Gimp benutzt, was tust du dann? Ist das ein Bild, sind das 100 Bilder, sind das irgendwie verschiedene Sachen, die du da machst? Arbeitest du da ganz im Detail irgendwo, oder ist das mehr so ein Kurzmalzuschneiden wieder weg? Und erst wenn man solche Arbeitsabläufe wirklich verstanden hat, kann man halt auch wirklich User Interface Design machen. Und Gimp hat dann auch schon noch einiges aufzuholen. Es ist halt ganz oft so, dass der Workflow irgendwie sperrig ist und viel zu viele Fenster gehen auf und springen irgendwo hin und so.
Da lernt man zuzuhören, oder? Ich mach das immer ganz gerne, so Software testen. Insbesondere, wenn dann so Leute, die es dann gehakt haben, dann sind sie so, hier mein tolles Programm, benutze doch mal. Oder ich sag einfach mal, okay, ich installiere mir das jetzt mal. Ich finde ja Programmierer dann ganz toll, so, oh, ein neuer User stürzt sich auf meine Software. Dann bin ich immer recht fies, weil ich starte dann die Software und starre sie erstmal eine Weile lang an. Das macht dann den Programmierer dann neben mir immer schon so ein bisschen nervös. Und dann fange ich einfach an, immer erstmal irgendwo hinzuklicken, was überhaupt nichts mit dem normalen Workflow zu tun hat. Einfachstes Beispiel, es startet mit einem Installer, und der hat dann so 3, 4, 5 Seiten, die er mich irgendwie abfragt. Und schon beim zweiten drücke ich dann erstmal auf Cancel. Da hat er noch nie drauf gedrückt. Weil warum sollte man den Cancel, man will ihn auch installieren. Es geht immer voran. Und ich drücke auf Cancel, mir fliegt das Ding um die Ohren und so weiter. Dann liege ich es gleich beiseite und sage, okay, fixen wir mal. Rufen mich wieder an, wenn es da ist. Gucken sie mal ganz böse. Ich verstehe dann aber erst mal gar nicht so richtig, worauf ich hinaus will. Dass man lernt, das Unerwartete zu tun. Und auch akzeptieren kann, dass Leute ganz andere Dinge tun, als man glaubt, dass sie eigentlich tun müssten. Wie läuft denn das jetzt? Wir haben jetzt ein großes Projekt, eine Software, die viele Leute benutzen. Wir wissen nicht, wie viele, aber ich denke, wir können davon ausgehen, dass wir hier mit fünfstelligen Benutzerzahlen zu tun haben weltweit, oder?
Der Download-Counter für den Windows-Installer hat letztens die Millionengrenze überschritten.
Der eine und derselben Version?
Da sind Updates mit drin. Das sind natürlich schon auch die User, die immer wieder die neue Version wieder runterladen, um sie vielleicht noch woanders zu installieren.
Aber bei Windows muss man ja auch alle paar Monate den Rechner neu installieren.
Genau, und deswegen kann man das durchaus nicht als Zahl zugrunde legen. Aber man kann das mal so im Kopf halten. Also, fünfstellig sind sie mal.
Habt ihr eine Software-Update-Funktion in eurem Programm drin, sodass irgendwie ein offenes Programm mal so checkt? Das ist ja gerade ganz hip, so eine Funktionalität. Da wüsstet ihr doch mal.
Nee, haben wir nicht. Was wir tatsächlich gerne eigentlich hätten, wäre, wir würden diese ganzen Plugins, die wir immer noch so mitschleppen, eigentlich größtenteils mal ausmisten. Und hätten die dann eigentlich ganz gerne irgendwo, sodass der User sie installieren kann, wenn er sie denn dann braucht.
So ein Repository online, so macht ihr das auch?
Wir haben im Prinzip ja so ein Repository, aber das ist halt zurzeit, da kannst du dann den Source Code runterladen. Und wenn du Glück hast, hat vielleicht auch jemand ein Binary hochgeladen, was gerade für dich funktioniert und so. Aber es ist halt nicht wirklich integriert. Was schon schön wäre, wobei das noch so ein bisschen wirklich in der Zukunft ist, weil da eigentlich gerade niemand aktiv dran arbeitet. Wäre, wenn man halt statt 150 Filter in den Menüs zu haben und damit den User halt auch vollkommen zu erschlagen, weil find da drin mal was, einfach eine ganz andere Rangehensweise an dieses Filter-Ding zu haben und irgendwie einen Dialog, wo du mit Bildern und einfachen Texten irgendwie erklärt kriegst und auch suchen kannst nach dem Filter, den du jetzt gerade brauchst, den du vielleicht einmal im Jahr brauchst für dieses eine Bild, dass du den dann einfach installieren könntest. Und das wäre halt schick, da hätten wir gerne sowas, so ein bisschen so Web-Integration, wobei das natürlich unheimlich schwierig ist bei einem Software, die auf zig Plattformen läuft.
Aber wenn so ein Software-Update, also ich meine, ich meine, bin da vielleicht jetzt ein bisschen verwöhnt auf dem Max, das mittlerweile gut ist in der Binär-Distribution sozusagen schon immer normal gewesen.
Also wenn ich mein Debian-Update mache, dann fällt da halt auch ein frisches Gimp rein, sobald wir ein Update gemacht haben. Der Debian-Gimp-Enthäner ist meistens so fix, der hat das Binary in Debian schon hochgeladen, bevor ich das Announcement noch gemacht habe.
Okay, aber es ist nicht das laufende Programm, das ist das, worauf ich gerade hinaus wollte. Also die Tools auf dem Mac ist halt mittlerweile voll angesagt, dass man eben einschalten kann, guck mal, ob es eine neue Version gibt. Das ist natürlich dann so ein bisschen, den kleinen Bruder des großen Bruders aufmacht. Und gut, das ist ja auch eine freiwillige Geschichte. Und ich sage dann, okay, ich sage jetzt auch dem Programmierer, dass ich gerade sein Programm gestartet habe, im Prinzip. Je nachdem, wie häufig das geht. Aber dadurch ist es natürlich für die Programmierer auch extrem wertvoll. Einige Entwickler haben dann eben auch ausführliche Statistiken aufgemacht, wo sie dann eben genau sagen können, unsere Benutzer haben die und die Version vom Betriebssystem, die und die Plattform, den und den Rechner, auf dem sie laufen und können natürlich dann auch viel genauer darauf hinarbeiten. Zu sagen, okay, das ist jetzt echt eine wichtige Plattform, weil da arbeiten viele Leute mit. Aber hier das Betriebssystem, was zehn Jahre alt ist, verwendet eben kein Mensch.
Du kannst da sogar noch viel weitergehen. Das haben auch Leute schon gemacht. Das ist noch recht jung, das Projekt sogar. Das ist tatsächlich mit GIMP gemacht worden. Die haben das instrumentalisiert. Das heißt, sie haben den GIMP-Sourcecode genommen, ein paar kleinere Änderungen vorgenommen und bieten eine Version an, die du installieren kannst. Die telefoniert quasi nach Hause und überträgt User-Daten in eine Datenbank rein, anonymisiert. Und zwar eben nicht nur, hier benutzt der User auf dem System das Programm, sondern auch der klickt vor allen Dingen dorthin und der benutzt dieses Plugin und der benutzt diesen Menüeintrag. Und im Endeffekt kannst du da Statistik über das Userverhalten machen.
Und das ist standardmäßig jetzt dabei?
Das ist nicht standardmäßig dabei, weil das auch viel zu spät im 2004-Zyklus, im Entwicklungszyklus quasi aufgetaucht ist. Das war jetzt ein Uni-Projekt.
Okay, also das ist noch relativ frisch.
Da hat jemand halt das an der Uni gemacht im Rahmen seiner Doktorarbeit oder so. Und die haben so ein bisschen da, dass theoretisch kann man sowas machen, wie funktioniert das, was kriegt man eigentlich für Daten gesammelt und so. Und wir denken jetzt schon drüber nach, das auch einzubauen. Das ist natürlich auch ein bisschen kritisch. Da muss man sich überlegen, wie bringt man das richtig rüber, dass der User das nicht in den falschen Hals kriegt. Es muss natürlich optional sein. Es muss ganz klar auch sein, irgendwie willst du das. Und es muss auch klar sein, welche Daten werden übertragen.
Ja, Fenster vorher aufmachen, wo genau gesagt wird, das wird jetzt übertragen. So läuft das ja auch mit Crash-Reports und so weiter auf anderen Systemen. Ich glaube sogar, dass die Akzeptanz davon sehr groß sein wird. Es gibt unter Garantie da so ein paar Schreihälse, die Verrat an allen Ecken wittern. Aber ich denke, dass die meisten Benutzer über so eine Funktion eher glücklich wären. Ich würde sowas sofort benutzen, weil man ist ja nur fair. Man kriegt Software kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt. Tausende nicht, aber viele Leute opfern extrem viel Freizeit um diese Software fertigzustellen. Warum sollte ich nicht sowas Einfaches machen, wie einfach nur anonym zu sagen, ich benutze die Software so und so, weil das kommt mir dann letztlich auch zugute, oder?
Ja, und helfen wird uns das sicher. Für mich sieht das zurzeit ein bisschen so aus, wenn sich jemand findet, der diesen Bereich ein bisschen maintainen will und mit uns Entwicklern daran arbeitet, das so einzubauen, dass es dann auch wirklich in der Hauptversion drin sein kann. Das kann man wahrscheinlich nicht ganz so eins zu eins übernehmen, was die da gemacht haben. Das ist schon mal ein guter Anfang. Dann könnte das durchaus seinen Einzug finden.
Wie viele Entwickler gibt es denn, die ihr so insgesamt, sagen wir mal, jetzt zu dieser Version 2.4 beigetragen haben? Also jetzt überhaupt? Also geschätzt?
Ja, es sind halt...
Zehn, hundert, tausend...
Es sind irgendwo zwischen zehn und hundert. Und da ist dann immer ein bisschen die Frage, wo setzt du so den Fokus? Es gibt halt tatsächlich bei den hundert ganz viele, die haben ein, zwei Kleinigkeiten gemacht. Und die Kleinigkeiten sind aber natürlich schon wichtig. Gerade in diesen hunderten von Plugins finden sich immer so viele Kleinigkeiten.
Klar. Und wie viele Leute tragen zu 95 Prozent das Code bei?
Fünf bis zehn.
Fünf bis zehn. Und das sind dann wahrscheinlich auch diejenigen, die im Wesentlichen dann in permanenter Kommunikation stehen. Kannst du mal ein bisschen sagen, wie das so abläuft? Was ist so der Gimp-Alltag als Entwickler und dann natürlich speziell auch als Maintainer, aber wie jetzt auch die anderen sozusagen teilen? Wie muss man sich so ein Open Source Projekt vorstellen? Wie geht das zusammen?
Bei uns läuft viel Kommunikation über die Mailing-Liste und aber auch über den IRC-Kanal. Also es gibt einen Gimp-Channel auf dem Gimp-Net sogar. Wir haben sogar so ein eigenes IRC-Net, wo auch der ganze Gnomen, GTK, Kram größtenteils drauf zu Hause ist. Viele Projekte haben da ihren Kanal. Und da hat man halt dann die Chance, ganz direkt mit Leuten zu sprechen und ganz direkt zu sagen, hier kannst du mal auf meinen Patch gucken, denkst du, das geht so, oder hier ist ein Screenshot, ich hab das gerade gehackt, denkst du, das ist so in Ordnung. Und da passiert ganz viel oder da wird halt irgendwie...
Wie viel Zeit bringst du in dem Chat so zu?
Ich hab den bei der Arbeit immer on. Das ist auch irgendwie so okay, weil ich da ja nur hin und wieder mal reinguck, aber man guckt da halt rein.
Das heißt, es läuft so ein bisschen, ist wie so Fernsehen in der Küche.
Es läuft so auf einem Desktop immer mal mit. Da guckt man dann mal, wenn man gerade mal zwischen zwei Sachen ist, mal kurz nochmal drauf und vielleicht hat auch jemand das gesagt, dann kann man mal kurz antworten. Und sonst passiert halt viel über Mailing-Liste und entwickelt wird halt...
Wie hoch ist die Aktivität auf der Mailing-Liste?
Also es gibt eine User- und eine Entwickler-Liste, wobei ich schon auch die User-Liste verfolge, um herauszufinden, so ein bisschen so...
Was die User sehen, da ist mehr los, nämlich anders als auf der Entwickler-Liste.
Da ist doch mehr los, auf jeden Fall, obwohl die allermeisten User sich tatsächlich in irgendwelchen Foren umheimen.
Weißt du, wie viele User da subscribiert sind auf der Mailing-Liste?
Tausende.
Tausende, okay.
Keine Ahnung, ich weiß es wirklich nicht. Es sind bestimmt hunderte, die sich schon mal dazu Wort gemeldet haben und ich glaube, so schnell an subscribt man sich gar nicht wieder. Auf der Entwickler-Liste sind zurzeit gerade viele Mails, aber sonst sind es halt so ein...
Wie viele Leute sind da subscribiert? Weiß ich auch nicht.
Weiß ich auch nicht, aber...
Haben sich auch schon ein paar Leute zu Wort gemeldet.
Haben sich doch auch schon ein paar Leute zu Wort gemeldet. Da sind auch nicht nur Entwickler tatsächlich, da sind halt auch viele, die so ein bisschen versuchen, in den Entwickler-Diskussionen so ein bisschen mitzumischen. Power-User. Power-User sind natürlich auch immer gern gesehen. Da hat man natürlich auch noch hin und wieder mal so Power-Schwätzer, die halt überall ihren Senf zugeben müssen, aber das...
Kriegt man schon rausgefiltert. Also Chat und Mailing-Liste ist sozusagen im Wesentlichen...
Und ja, was Entwicklung angeht, ist halt... Der Tagtrecker ist total wichtig und Subversion benutzen wir inzwischen als Source Code.
Also als Versionskontrolle, wo der eigentliche Code drin ist. Seit wann?
GNOME hat den Umstieg auf Subversion gemacht erst recht spät Anfang dieses Jahres oder so.
Und ihr seid mitmarschiert.
Wir haben halt schon immer da unseren Source-Code gehabt und da das auch eigentlich gut funktioniert...
Subversion ist ja schon eine deutliche Verbesserung gegenüber dem alten CVS-System. Hat sich das ausgewirkt so auf die Qualität oder die Komfortabilität des Hackens?
Ja, es gibt so ein paar Features in Subversion, die man halt jetzt nicht mehr missen will. Du konntest zum Beispiel vorher mit CVS nur ganz Schwänne-Datei mal umbenennen. Was man natürlich, wenn man Source Code wirklich mal überarbeitet, eigentlich an Dauern tun will. Ich split jetzt dieses Pfeil mal in zwei. Dann will ich eigentlich in beiden Pfeils die Versionshistorie immer haben. Und ich will die Dinge auch vielleicht manchmal einfach umbenennen, weil derjenige, der das da eingecheckt hat, war vielleicht nicht so geschickt da drin. Oder man hat sich irgendwie geändert und dann wandert das Ding von einem direkt ins andere und so. Das war früher mit CVS halt wirklich ein Grundstück. Wir haben das dann immer so gemacht, dass jemand, der Zugriff auf den CVS-Server hat, dann direkt in dem Repository, auf dem Server, da auf den Pfeils rumgehackt hat. Und soviel konnte man das immer noch irgendwie machen. Das ist schon besser jetzt mit Zapfwörchen.
Und das sind so die wesentlichen Tools. Also der Bug-Tracker und Zapfwörchen, um den einigen Code zu maintainen, und der Chat und die Mailing-Listen, um mit den Entwicklern zu diskutieren. Und dazu die regelmäßigen oder unregelmäßigen Treffen.
Dazu die regelmäßigen Treffen, was halt schon sehr motivierend immer ist. Halt auch einfach nett. Du triffst halt mal die ganzen Leute, die du sonst nur von Mailing-Listen kennst. Das kann auch sehr hilfreich sein, so zwischenmenschliche Probleme mal aus der Welt zu räumen. Also Leute, die sich auf der Mailing-Liste vielleicht überhaupt nicht vertragen haben. Wenn die erstmal ein paar Bier mit innen getrunken haben, dann wissen die plötzlich, der meint das ja gar nicht so. Das ist schon echt ganz gut.
Ja, kann hilfreich sein, real life.
Wirklich hoffe, dass wir vielleicht das verstärken können und nicht mehr nur noch diese großen einmal im Jahr treffen sich dann jetzt ein Dutzend Gimp-Entwickler und noch zwei Dutzend aus anderen Projekten, sondern dass wir vielleicht öfters mal so kleinere Meetings machen können. Jemand, der einfach Bock hat, an irgendeinem Feature zu hacken, fliegt einfach mal fürs Wochenende hier nach Berlin und setzt sich mit Peter, unserem User Interface-Mann zusammen und quatscht das einfach mal durch. Und setzt sich mal irgendwie auf ein Papier mit Mitch zusammen und die gehen mal so das Design durch oder irgendwie.
Das ist natürlich eine finanzielle Frage an der Stelle. Wie finanziert sich denn das Projekt? Ich meine, da sind ja so einige Kosten, das müssen Server betrieben werden.
So richtig viele Kosten in dem Sinne haben wir ja nicht mal. Wir haben unser Subversion Repository bei GNOME, wir haben unseren Bugcracker bei GNOME, wir haben den Server, wo die Mailing-Liste und die Webseite drauflaufen, in Berkeley immer noch stehen. Der Server ist zwar unser, und da muss man dann hin und wieder mal eine neue Festplatte verkaufen und so. Aber der Treffer geht auf die Uni, und der steht da irgendwo im Rack und zieht seinen Strom von denen. So richtig viel Geld braucht man gar nicht, um auch so ein großes Software-Projekt zu machen. Das meiste Geld, was wir ausgeben, geht tatsächlich für solche Treffen drauf. Weil natürlich, die Leute geben eh schon ihre ganze Freizeit für das Projekt her. Die sollen nicht auch noch den Flug und das Hotel bezahlen müssen.
Und wie könnt ihr das machen? Nehmt ihr Spenden an?
Wir haben bei den frühen Treffen eigentlich immer versucht, das über Sponsoring zu machen. Was dann aber ziemlich anstrengend sein kann. Du musst dann halt irgendwie los und Firmen anrufen und rumtelefonieren und betteln, dass sie dann vielleicht ihr mal ein paar tausend Euro geben und so weiter. Und haben vor zwei, drei Jahren angefangen, auch Spenden auf der Webseite anzunehmen. Und das läuft gar nicht so schlecht, obwohl wir das überhaupt nicht pushen, also überhaupt nicht dazu aufrufen, das zu machen. Kommt genug zusammen, um diese Treffen einmal im Jahr zu machen.
Wie kann man da was spenden?
Da gibt es einen Button auf der Gimp-Box-Seite, da klickst du drauf. Und dann kommst du auf eine Seite, wo du mit PayPal oder, ich glaube, auch per Scheck bezahlen kannst. PayPal macht das ja auch über Kreditkarte, also für die meisten Leute ist das wohl auch kein Problem.
Das heißt, wenn man jetzt regelmäßiger Gimp-Anwender ist und man benutzt das vielleicht sogar professionell und man hat da schon den einen oder anderen Nutzen rausgezogen und man möchte auch ganz gerne auch mal ein paar Dollar vielleicht wieder in die Entwicklung stecken, dann wäre das so der Weg der Wahl.
Ja, da kann man das so tun, wenn man das Gefühl hat, ich habe hier gerade ganz viel Geld gespart, weil ich vielleicht kein kommerzielles Produkt kaufen musste.
Und wenn man jetzt Entwickler ist und wenn man an dem Projekt teilnehmen möchte, weil man vielleicht so etwa die gleiche Motivation hat wie du, man ist eh im Bereich Bildbearbeitung aktiv, Studenten, Informatik-Studenten, die vielleicht ausgerechnet die Pixel-Welt jetzt für sich entdeckt haben und da auch neue Algorithmen vielleicht ausprobieren wollen und die was beizutragen haben. Was würdest du denen raten, wenn für die jetzt ein Gimp ein lohnenswertes Ziel wäre? Wie tritt man denn an euch heran? Redet ihr mit jemandem?
Definitiv über die Mailing-Liste. Also wer sich halt auf der Mailing-Liste irgendwie meldet, so ich habe Interesse, der wird zumindest mal freundlich begrüßt. Natürlich muss man dann schon auch ein bisschen Interesse zeigen. Was ich hoffe für die Zukunft, dass wir es ein bisschen einfacher machen können für neue Leute mit zu arbeiten, ist, dass wir die wichtigsten Aufgaben, die ja eigentlich dringend mal gemacht werden müssten, ein bisschen besser formulieren. Was ist eigentlich das, was so auf der To-Do steht? Und das Ganze dann auf der Webseite mal veröffentlichen. Wir haben das eigentlich schon in dem Bug-Tracker, aber das sind halt 550 Bugs. Es ist auch nicht so, dass jeder Enhancement-Request, der da drin steckt, wirklich verwirklicht werden sollte. Es ist dann teilweise halt so das Lieblingsfeature von irgendeinem User und passt gar nicht so richtig. Deswegen sind wir jetzt gerade dabei, mal so eine Liste von Aufgaben zu erstellen und dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu sagen, die sind wichtig, die wollen wir in 2.6. haben. Und da haben sich vielleicht auch schon für die ein oder anderen Leute gefunden, dass wir mir dann auch dabei schreiben. Der Task ist sozusagen schon so ein bisschen vergeben. Und da werden aber auch einige offene Aufgaben sein. Und das ist natürlich dann eine super Gelegenheit zu sagen, ich würde das gerne machen. Wo fange ich denn an?
Und dann wird man im Prinzip über die Mailing-Liste herangeführt und ihr schickt keinen weg, der für dich was beizutragen hat.
Wir haben auch so eine Liste von ganz kleinen Aufgaben. So auf Gäbelchen, wenn mal einer nochmal so schnuppern will. Also es gibt so eine Reihe von Bugs, die sind getaggt mit einem extra Keyword. Wo wir sagen, eigentlich müsste es ganz einfach sein. Und braucht auch nicht jetzt die tiefe Kenntnis des Gimps-Housecodes. Das ist ja doch eine ganze Menge. Und je nachdem, wo man ansetzt, kann das auch...
Man muss eigentlich nur die grundsätzliche Fähigkeit zum Programmieren mit sich bringen.
Wenn du C-Programmieren kannst, dann kannst du da anfangen. Und du wirst es wahrscheinlich quasi aus dem Stand an einem Wochenende irgendwie hinkriegen.
Und das machen jetzt andere nicht, weil man hat noch andere Sachen zu tun. Und wenn man sich nur um sowas kümmert, dann macht man auch nichts anderes mehr. Das ist dann sozusagen ein schöner Test. Das ist ja wahrscheinlich auch eine Methode, sich überhaupt erst mal mit der Struktur von Gimp vertraut zu machen. Ist ja sicherlich nicht gerade wenig Source Code, der da auf einen lauert, oder? So wie ein Überblick, wie viel Code da jetzt schon zusammengekommen ist.
Das ist eine ganze Menge.
Wird es eher mehr oder wird es weniger?
Es wird mehr. Es gab tatsächlich auch mal eine Zeit, da ist es kurz weniger geworden. Es gibt solche Messungen über die Anzahl der Zeilen auf Code, über die Zeit, da kann man so Statistiken machen. Da gab es in dieser Zeit, wo ich mit Mitch mal so viel Refactoring gemacht habe, sogar mal einen Moment, da ist es weniger geworden. Da haben wir dann tatsächlich es geschafft, unheimlich viel Code, der an vielen Stellen dupliziert war, einfach zu vereinen, indem man das Ganze mal auf so ein solides Vorgang gesetzt hat.
Also Refactoring ist der Vorgang, durch seinen Code durchzugehen und zu schauen, kann man das nicht auch anders machen und kann man das nicht vereinheitlichen und ziemlich Sachen ähnlich. Und dabei ist dann eine Menge rausgefallen.
Ja, aber im Endeffekt, das wächst halt immer weiter, weil du baust halt auch neue Features ein und du baust alles noch. Es wird halt ständig poliert und gemacht und es ist selten, dass es mal irgendwie weniger Zeilencodes sind. Also das ganze Ding wächst.
Aber der Code enthält auch Kommentare, ja?
Ja, enthält er schon. Allerdings, wenn man diesen Tools glauben soll, die sowas messen, dann ist der Anteil an Kommentaren im Gimp-Codes sogar eher unterdurchschnittlich.
Oh, ist das gut oder ist das schlecht?
Es kann gut und es kann schlecht sein. Also ich denke, der Code ist in großen Teilen inzwischen sehr leserlich. Viele Kommentare entstehen oft auch einfach, weil der Code so unglaublich unleserlich geschrieben ist, dass man ihn ohne Kommentare überhaupt nicht versteht. Also mir ist es ehrlich gesagt lieber, wenn ich den Code wirklich lesen kann, dann muss es auch nicht unbedingt an jeder Funktion noch eine lange Erklärung geben, was denn das Ding macht. Wenn der Funktionsname im Prinzip schon erklärt, was das Ding eigentlich tut, dann muss man das auch nicht noch kommentieren. Es gibt halt auch Leute, die schreiben, da steht dann über jeder Zeile drüber, was sie macht.
So A gleich Null, Moves Zero into A.
Ja, addierer A und B. Und da steht dann dann drunter C gleich A plus B.
Dafür ist ein Kommentar nicht eingeführt worden. Ja, aber wie ist denn der Umfang? Also wie viel Code gibt es denn, um so eine Vorstellung davon zu bekommen? Und wie viel Code, der heute noch existiert war, schon in der 1.0-Version drin?
Guck mal auf olo.net, da steht irgendwo dran, wie viele Programmierer du, wie viele Jahre in einem Käfig sperren müsstest, um den Code zu schreiben.
Wo muss ich da hinschauen?
Die machen Analysen von Open Source-Projekten und den Leuten, die daran arbeiten. Da kannst du im Prinzip gucken, wer wieviel Zeilen an GNOME oder GIMP oder so weiter besitzt und wieviel Zeilen Code es wirklich sind. Ich krieg es gerade aus dem Kopf nicht, wieviel es sind.
Das kannte ich noch gar nicht. Hier steht 683 Stacks, was immer das heißen mag. Ah, Activity Map. Steht da auch noch von, wo der Code eingecheckt wurde oder was?
Das sind...
Das sind irgendwelche Stacks, die hier angezeigt werden.
Leute, die sagen, dass sie das benutzen, glaube ich.
Gut, das sind sozusagen... Die Leute, die das benutzen, sind Stacks?
Die sich da in diesen Ding eingetragen haben. Das ist tatsächlich ein nicht so bekanntes Tool. Aber ich fand das ganz lustig. Ich habe das irgendwann entdeckt, dass es das da gibt und dass es...
Mhm, dass es da Statistiken darüber gibt.
Dass es da Statistiken darüber gibt, wie mein...
60 Prozent C oder C++...
Wie mein Code-Verhalten quasi ist. Da kann ich jetzt irgendwie nachschauen, wie viele Jahre ich schon C programmiere.
Also, Januar 01 waren es 1,25 Millionen Codes. Das zeige ich jetzt mal hier. Das steht hier nicht so genau, aber hier ist so eine Linie. Und dann wurde es bis Januar 03 locker 250.000 Zeilen weniger. Und seitdem geht es wieder bergauf. Ja, ich zeige dir das mal. Interaktives Podcasting hier.
Erstaunlich, wie dann da einfach... Mit weniger Code. Vielleicht haben wir auch einfach nur Kommentare rausgenommen.
Nee, habt ihr nicht, weil das ist nämlich hier auch noch auseinandergehalten. Also die Zahl der Kommentare möchte ich mal als relativ konstant angeben. Also es kam eigentlich nur noch Code dazu und kein einziger Kommentar. Schönes Tool, was nicht alles gibt, kannte ich noch nicht.
Guck mal, wenn du da ein bisschen runterscrollst, auf der Seite steht irgendwo...
Haben sie so ein interaktives Scrolling? Nee, Tiva geht es nicht.
Dann haben sie es schon wieder geändert und finde ich es nicht. Aber das können ja dann die Hörer mal nachschauen, wenn sie es interessant finden.
olo.net, schön bunt Open Source zum bunt klicken. Das ist doch schon mal was. Ja, wo geht denn die Reise jetzt hin mit Gimp? Also hast du ja schon gesagt, Vision 2.6. Alles wird besser und es gibt neue Überwachungstools in der Software, um den Benutzer auszuforschen. Was haben wir denn noch zu erwarten?
Also es gibt zwei Fronten quasi, an denen wir arbeiten wollen in der nächsten Zeit. Das wird nicht alles in 2.6 fertig werden, weil wie gesagt, wir wollen ja jetzt schnell releasen und viele kleine Releases machen. Aber es gibt zwei wichtige Aufgaben. Das eine ist, wir wollen das User Interface doch stark überarbeiten. Ein bisschen auch weg von diesen mehrere Fenster, die sich dann irgendwie auf dem Bildschirm befinden und in irgendeinem Bezug zueinander stehen oder nicht stehen.
Sondern mehr so ein Single-Window-Interface zu machen?
Ja, sowas in die Richtung. Also es wird wohl immer noch die Möglichkeit geben, auch mit mehreren Monitoren vernünftig zu arbeiten, was ja ein Problem ist bei diesen reinen Einfenster-Lösungen. Aber wir werden definitiv mehr in die Richtung arbeiten, dass wenn du an einem Bild arbeitest, du die Sachen, die Werkzeuge alle an dem Bild irgendwo hast und irgendwo alles im Griff hast und auch in deiner Tastleiste Gimp als eine Anwendung erscheint und nicht als Namalsurium von Fenstern. Das ist sicher auch eine Herausforderung, das so hinzukriegen, dass das eine wirkliche Verbesserung ist und dass es auch auf allen Plattformen funktioniert. Aber da bin ich ganz zuversichtlich, dass das so mit der ganzen Arbeit, die schon an User Interface, Evaluation und so gelaufen ist, dass das kommen wird. Da machen wir schon mal einen Schritt in 2.6 auf jeden Fall. Und die andere Aufgabe ist, dass wir unseren internen Grafikkern, wo wirklich die Pixel manipuliert werden, den jetzt endlich dann doch auch mal überarbeiten werden, um damit wegzukommen von der Beschränkung auf 8 Bit pro Farbkanal RGB.
Dann ist höhere Auflösung auch wichtig.
Höhere Auflösung und auch andere Farbräume, wobei tatsächlich der Fokus erst mal auf höhere Farbtiefe stehen wird.
Also dass man 16 Bit Auflösung, Graustufen usw. bearbeiten kann.
16 Bit Graustufen, was viele Kameras, also professionellere Spiegelreflexkameras zum Beispiel heutzutage liefern, sind halt 16 Bit pro Farbkanal Farbbilder. Die Dinger haben in Wirklichkeit nur 12 Bit oft. Klar, aber wenn man es schon mehr als acht hat. Es ist definitiv mehr Farbinformation, als Gimp zur Zeit handeln kann. Was halt zur Zeit bedeutet, wenn du so ein Bild in Gimp öffnest, dann schmeißt du Information weg. Da gibt es dann zwar Plugins, die dir immerhin schon mal die ersten Schritte der Farbkorrektur, die man so macht, die Belichtung korrigieren, die das quasi in dem Plugin noch in 16 Bit pro Kanal machen. Und damit kannst du dann schon so einigermaßen diesen Dingern mit Gimp arbeiten. Aber eigentlich, du hast dir so eine teure Kamera gekauft und die hat dieses Feature und die hat diese Möglichkeit, auch ein unterbelichtetes Bild nachträglich noch zu zu korrigieren.
Redest du jetzt von RAW auch?
Das sind tatsächlich dann auch immer diese RAW-Formate. Einfach aus dem Grund, dass JPEG überhaupt nicht mehr als 8 Bit pro Kanal so unterstützt.
Und RAW ist ja jetzt auch sehr verbreitet. Also so ein Profibereich, kenne da so. Also ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt schon die Mehrheit ist, aber ich habe bei professionellen Fotografen, die so mit Digitalkameras arbeiten, großes Interesse gefunden, weil man halt so Weißabgleichen und so was alles nachträglich machen kann.
Die wollen halt genau dieses Feature haben. Du willst halt nachträglich noch sagen können, ich habe aber hier eine halbe Blende zu niedrig und die ziehe ich jetzt einfach rauf. Und wenn du das mit einem 8 Bit Bild machst, dann bedeutet das, dass vielleicht, wenn du es ein bisschen heller machst, dass die Bereiche, die eh schon sehr hell waren, ins Weiß gehen und Abstufungen, die da waren, komplett verloren gehen. Und die sind dann endgültig verloren. Das heißt, du kannst auch nicht, wenn du danach sagst, dann ziehe ich noch ein bisschen Kontrast rein, um das wieder rauszuholen, diese Nuancen, die sind halt weg. Die Information ist dann einfach verloren gegangen in dem Moment.
Diese Rohrbilder sind aber extrem rechnintensiv dann auch.
Du brauchst halt dann doppelt so viel Speicherplatz. Allein schon, um das Bild zu halten. Das bedeutet auch, im Gimp intern brauchst du doppelt so viel Speicherplatz. Was aber heutzutage auch nicht mehr so ein Problem ist. Wenn man sich überlegt, wie viel RAM da mal so drin war, als ich mein erstes Gimp irgendwie benutzt habe und was heute dazu gehört.
Da schmeißt man halt nochmal zwei Gigabyte hinterher, wenn man sie braucht.
Ich brauche halt nochmal ein paar Gigabyte hinterher und auch die Festplatten sind ja auch groß genug, sodass das alles gar nicht mehr so ein Problem ist. Diese Rohrbilder sind halt auch riesig auf der Platte.
Ich mache dir jetzt so von der Aufbereitung her. Kannst du das vielleicht mal kurz erläutern? Das ist ein bisschen neben dem Thema arm. Ich würde es nochmal interessieren. Also diese Rohrbilder speichern ja die Bilder quasi so, wie sie aus dem Chip fallen, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Was ist da der technische Unterschied zu den JPEGs?
Ja, die kommen halt tatsächlich so, wie die aus dem Chip fallen. Das heißt, es ist eigentlich erst mal ein graues Stufenbild bloß. Also der Chip hat halt einfach nur sozusagen Helligkeitsinformation. Und dann sind auf diesen Chips Farbfilter drauf. Das heißt, jede dritte Pixel ist rot gefiltert. Und du hast also sozusagen ein graues Stufenbild, auf dem jeder dritte Pixel als Rotinformation zu deuten ist. Und jeder in so einem Raster da drauf, rot, grün, blau, rot, grün, blau, immer wieder auftaucht. Daraus musst du jetzt erst mal die Farbinformation erstellen. Das machen normalerweise die Kameras sofort.
Automatisch schon?
So, die machen das sofort. Dann machen die gleich bei der Gelegenheit noch einen Weißabgleich mit. Und komprimieren das Ganze dann in JPEG. Dabei wird auch noch komprimiert eben. Da geht auch noch ein bisschen was verloren. Und das alles vermeidest du halt, wenn du RAW fotografierst.
Also man hat zwei große Dateien.
Der Effekt ist, du hast große Dateien. Du hast aber alles noch in der Hand. Bei diesem Umbauen von diesem Graustufenbild in das Farbbild wird halt auch noch ein bisschen weichgezeichnet. Es wird nachher noch ein bisschen geschärft. Manch einem gefällt es halt auch nicht, was die Kamera da macht. Und die sagen halt, ich kann das selber besser. Und ich will irgendwie überall meine Finger im Spiel haben. Ich will auch da noch kontrollieren, den Radius von dem Weichzeichner, der angewendet wird, nachdem die Farben separiert wurden.
Aber RAW ist ja nicht gleich RAW. Also es gibt ja schon Unterschiede in den einzelnen Kameraformaten.
Das ist für die Open Source Geschichten natürlich ein echtes Problem, weil jeder Kamerahersteller sein eigenes RAW-Format backt.
Und die machen das auch nicht unbedingt publik, wie das aufgebaut ist?
Es gibt da Unterschiede. Es gibt die einen, die sogar so weit gehen, dass sie bestimmte Metainformationen verschlüsseln, sodass du im Prinzip da gar nicht mehr drankommst. Das heißt, du kannst nicht herausfinden, wie die genaue Sensoreinstellung von der Kamera war, wenn du nicht von dem Kamerahersteller die Software verwendest. Inzwischen ist es natürlich so, du kannst nichts wirklich so verbergen, dass ein kluger Mensch es nicht doch irgendwie rausfinden könnte, dass es halt die allermeisten Kameraformate wohl doch inzwischen importiert werden können. Es gibt da halt Bibliotheken, die man benutzen kann, die die allermeisten RAW-Formate lesen. Ich bin nicht so ganz drin in der Thematik. Ich weiß es nicht, ob das immer noch wirklich ein Problem ist. Wahrscheinlich sollte man gucken, bevor man sich eine Kamera kauft, wenn man irgendwelche Open Source Tools verwenden will.
Also geht denn RAW jetzt schon heute mit Gimp?
Ja, es gibt ein Plugin, das mindestens eins, das ist das UF RAW, das die meisten Leute verwenden, das RAW-Dateien von so ziemlich allen Kameras auch öffnet und eben auch schon diese erste Umwandlung in das 8-Bit-RGB-Bild vornimmt und dem User dabei schon sehr viele Möglichkeiten gibt, da auch einzugreifen. Das heißt, du siehst schon im Preview von dem Bild, du siehst die Histogramm-Kurven, du kannst den Weißabgleich, die Helligkeitsabstung, das alles schon machen und dann mit dem 8-Bit-RGB-Bild weiterarbeiten. Das heißt, die allermeisten Vorteile von RAW-Fotografie hast du damit auch.
Und bei GIMP 2.6 kann man dann hoffen, dass da vielleicht die Sachen sich so langsam verbessern. Aber wir wollen jetzt nicht...
Ich mag nicht so viel versprechen, wenn ich auch gleichzeitig sage, dass es irgendwie bald fertig sein soll. Aber was wir halt machen werden, ist, wir werden... Also es gibt schon eine Bibliothek, Kegel, die Generic Graphics Library, die das bereits unterstützt. Das heißt, hier ist Arbeiten in hohen Farbtiefen von vornherein, vom Design her vorgesehen gewesen. Das heißt, alles wird erst mal Referenzimplementierung in Floating Point gemacht. Hier geht es gar nicht mehr um 16-Bit oder irgendwas, sondern da gibt es quasi unendlich viel Farbtiefe. Wobei aber schon auch vorgesehen ist, das Ganze dann für 8-Bit und 16-Bit zu optimieren. Damit du nicht immer alles in Floating Point... Weil dann brauchst du nicht nur doppelt so viel Speicherplatz, sondern irgendwie achtmal so viel.
Ja, 64 Bit dann für eine große Float-Zahl. Verstehe. Das heißt, das ist im Wesentlichen eigentlich so das, was im Mittelpunkt steht.
Für 2.6 wollen wir jetzt Gegel in den Kern einbauen. Das heißt, das wird sich wahrscheinlich für den User nicht so schrecklich viel tun.
Aber für die Plug-In-Entwickler unter Umständen?
Das ist auch noch fraglich, ob wir schon ein Plug-In-Interface wirklich machen. Aber wir werden definitiv die Interna schon mal auf Gegel umbauen. Dabei sehen wir dann auch, wo es noch hakt. Wo muss vielleicht in Gegel auch noch was gemacht werden?
Und dann kommt ja schon das nächste RNG, sechs Monate später?
Genau, und das nächste kommt ja schon bald. Also zurzeit wollen wir selber erst mal so ein bisschen auch den Stolzes Quo wieder herstellen. Ja, auch so ein bisschen herausfinden, wie funktioniert das mit Gegel eigentlich alles. Und wie kriegen wir das am besten nachher auch in die Plug-Ins rüber. Man muss ja auch ein bisschen aufpassen, wenn man so Plug-In-APIs kreiert, dann legt man sich auch fest. Dann muss man dann auch später lange die immer noch wieder unterstützen.
Klar. Ja, na jetzt haben wir aber einen schönen, schön umfangreichen Blick getätigt. Gibt es denn so aus deiner Perspektive jetzt noch etwas, was man vielleicht erwähnen sollte, aus der Benutzer- oder Entwicklerperspektive auf das Programm? Oder ein Wunsch?
Ja, also ich wünsche mir schon, dass wir mehr frische Entwickler kriegen. Das ist etwas, was mir jetzt doch sehr im Herzen liegt, weil so die Riegel wird alt. Die Leute, die vor Jahren das mal als Studenten irgendwie gemacht haben, viele von denen sind immer noch dabei, sind immer noch aktiv, wenn sie auch vielleicht oft nur noch auf der Mailing-Liste oder bei der Maintainance helfen. Aber es fehlt manchmal so ein bisschen an diesen Leuten, die noch 12 Stunden am Tag nichts anders machen als Gimp Haken. Da komme ich halt auch nicht mehr zu.
Das kann man nicht ewig machen. Aber hast du mal gemacht.
Ja, doch. Mitch und ich hatten ja auch noch irgendwann mal ein paar Monate, wo wir in einer Firma gearbeitet haben, wo es eigentlich nichts mehr zu arbeiten gab. Weil das Ganze eh sozusagen schon Bankrott war. Wir sind da halt eigentlich nur noch morgens hin und haben Gimp gehackt bis nachts um zwölf und am nächsten Tag wieder. So einen Schub könnte das Raum auch mal wieder gebrochen.
So eine New Economy-Phase im Zusammenbruch.
Es ist nicht so, dass wir nicht auch neue Entwickler hätten. Aber ich wünsche mir doch, dass das mehr werden.
Es könnten noch mehr sein. Ja, ich meine, es ist ja ein attraktives Projekt mit viel Vergangenheit und auch viel Gegenwart. Viele User. Das kann ja auch nicht jedes Programm so von sich behaupten. Und sicherlich auch noch eine ganze Menge Anwendungsmöglichkeiten in der Zukunft. Das sind ja noch nicht gerade aussterbende Spezies, wenn man sich anschaut, was im kommerziellen Bereich an Bildbearbeitungs- oder auch Bildverarbeitungssoftware kommt. Also gerade so lichttisch orientierte Bildbearbeitung, wo es gar nicht darum geht, jedes Pixel einzeln zu bearbeiten, sondern wo man eigentlich nur diese ganzen Einstellungen und diesen Raw-Import usw. macht oder Bilder sortieren und sammeln. Da haben wir schon vor ein paar Jahren mal darüber geredet. Ist denn der Gimps-House Code jetzt so modular, dass man darüber nachdenken könnte, eben auch so verschiedene Anwendungsarten aus derselben Codebasis abzuleiten, dass man also so ein Leuchttischprogramm hat auf der anderen Seite. Oder was ich mir immer wünsche, ist einfach so ein kleines Programm, was einfach nur Resizing und Copying irgendwie ordentlich macht, weil das einfach das ist, was 99,999% aller Fälle ist, das ist bei mir die Bildbearbeitung. Und vielleicht noch die Levels angleichen, also ich nehme mir so ein Bild und mir braucht das eine richtige Größe und ich will das nochmal resizing und dann mache ich es nochmal irgendwie in hübsch und dann speichere ich das ab. Ist das schon so ein Werkzeugkasten, dass man sagen kann, ok, jetzt baue ich aus Gimp Minigims, die auf bestimmte Sachen hin optimiert sind?
Ich denke, es ist durchaus machbar, aber es ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht ganz so einfach, wie du es gerne hättest. Heute setze ich mich mal eben hin und mache das. Da wäre halt schon noch mehr Arbeit möglich, aber ich halte es heute für wesentlich einfacher, das zu tun, als es noch vor ein paar Jahren war. Ich denke, es wird auch immer einfacher werden, einfach weil wir immer mehr Funktionalität kapseln und klar voneinander trennen, um auch diese Millionen-Zeilen-Code irgendwo übersichtlich zu halten. Du willst halt auch, dass wenn jemand ein neues Feature bauen will, der halt nicht diesen ganzen Code kennen muss von vorne bis hinten. Gegel wird sicher ein bisschen was in die Richtung bringen, was du sagst, dass man das auch für andere Anwendungen benutzt. Ganz einfach, weil wir sehr viel von diesen Filtern und eben diese ganze Pixel-Manipulations-Algorithmen werden in Gegel landen. Viele Plugins werden einfach als Gegel-Operationen nennen. Und Gegel ist von vornherein so designed, dass es halt nicht für Gimp ausschließlich ist. Es gibt auch tatsächlich jetzt schon zwei, drei Projekte, die auch schon so ein bisschen Gegel benutzen.
Es gibt es ja schon eine Weile.
Es gibt schon eine Weile, aber erst seit ein paar Jahren jetzt wieder aktiv in der Entwicklung und auch eigentlich erst seitdem es jetzt vor allen Dingen von Pipin gepflegt und weiterentwickelt wird, überhaupt mehr an den Punkt gekommen, dass du es auch benutzen kannst.
Und zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo es in Gimp landet, ist es dann natürlich sicherlich eine deutliche Aufwertung des Subsystems, sodass sich das andere noch mal genauer anschauen werden. Ja, fein.
Ja, wo wir da im Endeffekt hinwollen, also es ist schon aufregend, es geht halt nicht nur um ein bisschen mehr Farbtiefe, sondern wir wollen halt auch irgendwo hin zur verlustfreien Bildbearbeitung. Das heißt, du malst nicht mehr da irgendwo drüber oder machst wirklich einen Blur, der dann, und das ist dann halt passiert, so. Sondern du kannst irgendwann zurückgehen und kannst sagen, an dem Blur da oben habe ich aber doch ein bisschen arg irgendwie aufgetragen, ich drehe jetzt mal den Radius von dem Blur zurück und wanders sozusagen nicht nur in deiner History zurück und machst das Ganze wieder, sondern das ganze Bild existiert gar nicht in dem Sinne als fester Zustand, sondern das Bild ist das Ergebnis von Operationen. Und du kannst im Prinzip, wenn du dann nach zwei Stunden Bildbearbeitung fertig bist, kannst du sagen, wenn ich jetzt am Anfang nicht das Bild aufgemacht hätte, sondern das andere. Was wäre denn dann dabei rausgekommen? Und dann gehst du einfach hin und stöpselst aus diesem Netz von Operationen das eine Bild um, und guckst mal, was hinten rauskommt.
Das heißt, während ich normal mit dem Programm arbeite, definiere ich eigentlich so einen Workflow, so einen Ablauf. Und das ist dann quasi, ich skripte eigentlich nur noch.
Und das ist eine Herausforderung auch vom User Interface?
Auch für die CPU?
Auch für die CPU. Aber ich denke, die CPU und der Speicher, die werden mithalten. Die ganzen Ideen sind nicht neu. Die hatten wir schon 2000 auf dem Mkon, als wir im Club gesessen haben in der Rhinstraße und Wüsteszeug auf dem Overhead-Projekt designt haben. Und da wäre das alles noch nicht so richtig drin gewesen. Aber mit den Mitteln heutzutage, Gegel hat so eine kleine Anwendung dabei, wo man das schon so ausprobieren kann. Da kannst du dir den Baum von Operationen zusammenbauen und das wird live gerendert.
Ist denn daran zu denken, dass noch andere Teile aus Gimp so komplett ausgegliedert werden, wie das eins mit dem GTK geschehen ist? Auch wieder jetzt so im Hinblick auf nutzbar in anderen...
Was ich ganz gerne hätte, wäre, dass man vielleicht ein paar von den Widgets, die wir dringend brauchen, entweder halt in GTK einbaut oder vielleicht mal so eine Bibliothek von Widgets für Grafikprogramme schafft. Weil du brauchst einfach so Grafikprogramme, andere User Interface Elemente. Aber die Zusammenarbeit mit den anderen Projekten ist ja da, also da wird sich das schon ergeben. Würde sich das schon ergeben.
Gut, ich denke, jetzt haben wir doch hier einen sehr umfangreichen Blick auf Entwicklungen und Hintergründe und auch technische Finessen von Gimp zusammengetragen. Du hast ja daran gezweifelt, dass man zwei Stunden lang über Gimp reden kann, aber so ist es nun gekommen. Zwei-Stunden-Marke ist gerade gefallen und ich denke, man könnte sich auch noch viel länger darüber unterhalten, aber wir wollen ja hier auch halbwegs kompakt zusammenfassen. Zu interessanten Themen war alles Mögliche bei Chaosradio Express. Insofern sage ich jetzt Tschüss, Sven, und auch Tschüss an die Hörer. Wir hören uns sicherlich bald wieder beim nächsten Chaosradio Express.